Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Und wie lief es bei euch Jett gestern Abend?
Schön pepofett gemacht, also ich hab massive pepofett gemacht gestern, aber richtig.
Ultra pepofett habe ich gemacht gestern, ich glaube ich hab fast ein Baguette alleine gefressen
mit zwei drauf, komplettes.
Ach Geschenke gibt es bei euch erst am zweiten, okay wer macht denn sowas?
Okay immer noch besser als die Amis mit ihren komischen Socken und sowas, habe ich auch noch
nie verstanden.
Der echte ancient smith ist da, 30 Monate schon, danke schön für den Sub, aber ich
bin froh, dass der echte ist, massive Subscriptions hier, Naisu, ach so okay, das hat eher organisatorische
Gründe, small access point, 13 Monate, danke schön für die Subs Leute, ja ich bin auch
schon wieder bestimmt eine Stunde auf, aber trotzdem, wirklich wach bin ich noch nicht,
aber das ist ja heute auch nicht schlimm, nichtsdestotrotz ich freue mich, wisst ihr
worauf ich mich freue, nächste Woche wird sie laut oder, warte mal, Scantrain, danke
schön für die Bits, wird sie laut, wird sie so schlecht abgemischt, aber das geht jetzt
wieder, ja da müssen wir vielleicht eine andere Playlist gleich machen, so wisst ihr
was ich sagen wollte, wisst ihr worauf ich mich wirklich freue nächste Woche, also was
ich auch erst seit gestern sicher machen kann, und zwar ich freue mich drauf, Alter die Musik,
die ist komisch, die ist mal leise und mal laut, komm wir machen die Playlist an, die
ich gestern auch, nee das hatte ich gestern nicht an, was hatten wir denn gestern, glaubt
ich, was ist das da, ja deutlich angenehmer, genau und was was ich auch erst seit gestern
sicher machen kann, und zwar nächste Woche werde ich das hier ausdrucken und noch ordentlich
ausfüllen, dann werde ich das abgeben, ok 8er, 12er ist vielleicht ein bisschen verkehrt
Schreiber, Schreibern war das Aktuelles hin, 20.12, und dann werde ich das in die Personalabteilung
bringen, mit meinem Kollege zusammen, der auch nächstes Jahr dann mit mir quasi wechselt
zu einem neuen Arbeitgeber, wir gehen ja zum gleichen Laden, und dann werde ich das nächsten
Mittwoch wahrscheinlich, Dienstag oder Mittwoch abgeben und dann ist das endlich für mich
erledigt, wurde auch mal Zeit, dann ist das abgehakt, da freue ich mich wirklich drauf
die Kündigung abzugeben, dass wirklich jetzt mal Ruhe ist bei der ganzen Geschichte, dann
bin ich noch quasi drei komplette Monate da, und dann CU, genau, an was Neues, also ich
würde es wahrscheinlich so machen, also ich habe ja, so Januar bin ich komplett da, Februar
bin ich komplett da, und März, was es laggt, ach nee nicht schon wieder oder, es laggt
hier überhaupt nichts, aber davon weiß man nie, aber es laggt nicht, was wollte ich jetzt,
warte mal, irgendwie hat es mich, wie viele Überstunden abzubauen, keine, ja zumindest,
zumindest jetzt gerade nicht mehr, hat er schon seinen Grund, die Sounds, Alter warum
ist das manchmal so, ich verstehe das nicht, warum ist das, warum buggt das Sound manchmal
rum, also in manchen Streams ist das und in manchen nicht, warte mal, so reload, reload,
beim Browser reloaden buggt das manchmal, egal, es wird Zeit, dass ich auf den neuen
Rechner wechsle, also hier ist nix, hat sich nix, hat nix geruckelt, ja keine Ahnung, wird
Zeit echt auf den neuen Rechner zu wechseln, dann ist das hoff, da sind die Probleme hoffentlich
dann auch alle weg, wer weiß, wer weiß, was hier gerade wieder abgeht, Windows, Windows
Zeug, Windows, keine Ahnung, muss man nicht verstehen, zumindest Plan ist ja folgendes,
also Januar noch komplett da, Dienstag noch komplett da, Januar noch komplett da, Januar
noch komplett da, Januar noch komplett da, Januar noch komplett da, Januar noch komplett
da, Januar noch komplett da, Januar noch komplett da, Januar noch komplett da, Januar noch komplett
da, Januar noch komplett da, Februar noch komplett da, Februar noch komplett da, so
hier fange ich beim neuen an, und theoretisch würde ich hier beim alten erst aufhören,
aber es gibt noch 6 Urlaubstage,ence drin, an denen ich
was steht als Turr, ich bin immer noch einmal aus der Somebody News sekarang zurückうわ,
also Unless I Am Decib oy, also hierarte bin ich nachher, dieses Jahr noch monster Orange
Quaker sortiert TV AD, STWR TV, weil es ja so zsswater Syin und so und dann, also das
Und je nachdem wie viele Stunden ich dann hab, vielleicht auch die Woche noch früher weg.
Und wahrscheinlich ist der 17.3. dann der letzte Tag.
Ja, wilder Igel, ich hätt es früher auch nicht geschafft.
Aber ich will halt so seamless weiterarbeiten können.
Also ich will alles, dass alles drüben schon eingerichtet ist, wenn ich umstöpsel.
Seamless, achja, ja, so ist das ganze geplant und da bin ich mal wirklich gespannt drauf.
Ich freu mich wirklich schon auf die neue Geschichte.
Hatte ich jetzt eine ganze Weile nicht mehr, da hab ich wirklich gesagt, ich freu mich
mal wieder auf die Arbeit zu gehen.
Also so richtig, ich bin echt gespannt drauf, was man so alles machen kann.
Was man bauen kann, was man programmieren kann, was man verbessern kann.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich jetzt sagen würde, oh alter, ich geh da überhaupt nicht gerne
hin.
Die Arbeit an sich ist überhaupt nicht das Ding, also die Arbeit würde ich auch so noch
weiter machen.
Das ist ja nicht das, was mich nervt.
Also die Arbeit an der Arbeit ist nicht das, was mich stört.
Na ja, irgendwie bin ich müde.
Erzählt mal, gibt es irgendwas spannendes?
Vor allem, wenn wir uns jetzt ein paar YouTube Videos und Sachen angucken, wie das üblich
ist, gibt es irgendwas spannendes?
Ja, das ist klar.
Ich glaube, das geht keiner aktuell.
Okay, da muss zumindest schon blöd sein, wenn ihr davon ausgeht.
Ich glaube, niemand der Wechsel geht davon aus, dass bei den anderen alles toll ist.
Es gibt sicherlich auch Sachen, die einem auf den Keks gehen, das ist normal.
Gerade weil das auch ein großer Laden ist, da gibt es bestimmt wieder irgendwelche bürokratischen
Sachen, die dir auf den Keks gehen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das ist ja bei dem jetzigen auch so, das sind dann halt vielleicht andere
Sachen, aber dafür gibt es die Dinger, weshalb ich denn auch wechseln will, nicht.
Die Katze, die war gestern irritiert.
So mit Lichter im Wohnzimmer und sowas, das kannt sie nicht, das hat sie verwirrt.
Aber ich habe was blödes gemacht gestern noch, ich glaube, ich habe es auch auf Twitter gepaust
gemacht.
Nitter, gucken wir mal, gestern noch gepaust, guck mal, ich habe Firmware-Update gemacht
vom Weihnachtsbaum und ich habe Firmware-Update gemacht vom Weihnachtsbaum, 10 Minuten oder
so, bevor es losging.
Das war keine allzu gute Idee.
Ich habe Firmware-Update angeschmissen, das macht man ja über ein Browser, das hast du
Upload, neues Firmware-File und dann ist es erstmal hängen geblieben beim Upload und
ich dachte, oh fuck, was jetzt, aber es hat dann 3, 4 Minuten gedauert und auf einmal
war das Ding wieder da.
Also ich kann sagen, es ist keine gute Idee, Firmware-Update für den Weihnachtsbaum zu
machen, 5 Minuten bevor es losgeht.
Also nicht für den Weihnachtsbaum, sondern für die Beleuchtung, es ist ja nicht der
Weihnachtsbaum, der ein Firmware-Update kriegt, sondern die Beleuchtung.
Der Controller liegt hier hinten, den sieht man jetzt auf dem Bild nicht, guck, der Controller
liegt hier hinten.
Also hier sehen wir ja die Kabel und hier hinten liegt er, hier sieht man, hier sieht
man den Anschlusskabel für die RGB-LEDs, es sieht so aus, als sind die alle weiß,
sind sie aber nicht.
Ich glaube, wenn man das weiß, dass das kein Kamerafehler ist, also die Dinger sehen wirklich
unterschiedlich hell aus.
Dass sie ein bisschen unterschiedliche Farbe haben, ist jetzt tatsächlich ein Kameraproblem,
aber es ändert sich nur, die grundsätzliche Farbe ist nicht so, dass der hier grün ist
und der hier rot, sondern es ist eigentlich Richtung orange, aber die Helligkeit wird
bei allen LEDs so leicht variiert, immer wieder, sodass das so leicht nach Kerze, so leicht
nach Kerze aussieht, deswegen sind die wirklich unterschiedlich hell.
Genau, Kerzeneffekte, dahinter ist hier die Steuerung, warum braucht ein Weihnachtsbaumbeleuchtung
Firmware, dass du z.B. die ganze Sache übers Handy steuern kannst, dass du die Farben ändern
kannst, die Helligkeit ändern kannst, die Effekte ändern kannst, also da ist WLED drauf,
wie bei den meisten Sachen, die LED, also ziemlich beliebtes Projekt auch und so sieht
das Webinterface dann zum, na geiles Bild aller, Hauptsache super Ultra High Res, so
sieht das Webinterface von dem Ding aus, kannst Effekte einstellen, Effekt Speed, kannst Presets
einstellen, so und ich hab an der Steuerung, die man jetzt hier nicht sieht, also dahinten
ist Steuerung, das ist ein ESP, ich glaube es ist ein ESP32, irgendeiner, irgendein billiger
ESP32 und da hab ich auch noch einen Knopf in das Gehäuse reingemacht, da kannst du
zwischen zwei Presets umschalten, ich hab zwei Presets, einmal den normalen Weihnachtsbaum
Modus, also orangenes Licht und Kerzeneffekt und dann hab ich noch komplett weiß ohne Effekte,
da kann man umschalten, wenn man einfach mal kurzzeitig ein bisschen Licht braucht und
nicht irgendwie großartig Licht, der im Wohnzimmer einschalten will, also wenn ich es einfach
nur komplett hell haben will, mal ganz kurz, dann leg ich den Knopf um, dann ist halt quasi
das Weihnachtsbaum Feeling weg, sondern alle LEDs sind Max Helligkeit und weiß, du siehst
halt schön was und mach ich es wieder in normalen Modus, dann sieht es halt am Weihnachtsbaum
aus.
Ja und da hab ich Firmware Update gemacht, weil der Grund, also es hat ja so, einfach
Just For Fun ist der nicht, der Grund war, weil ich hab in meinem Home Assistant das
aufgemacht, den Weihnachtsbaum, ich hab eingeschaltet, hab im Home Assistant den Weihnachtsbaum
aufgemacht und hab festgestellt, das connectet sich nicht mehr und da dachte ich, die WLAN,
die WLED Version wäre zu alt für die aktuelle Home Assistant Version, weil es gab immer
irgendeinen komischen Fehler beim Verbinden, bis ich dann nachher festgestellt hab, nein,
das lag nicht an der WLED Version, sondern irgendwie sind meine Presets kaputt gegangen,
da hab ich die Presets nochmal gelöscht und schnell neu gemacht und dann ging alles
und das hab ich alle so in 10 Minuten gemacht, bevor die ganze Weihnachtsgeschichte losging,
das war schon recht, war schon recht knapp alles, ja, also der Weihnachtsbaum ging quasi
so 2 Minuten bevor es losging, also ich hab das gepostet um 17 Uhr, nein, wann hab ich
das gepostet?
Was, 17.27 Uhr, oder ist das 18 Uhr, nein, 17, ach UTC, UTC, nein, das ist 18.27 Uhr,
18.27 Uhr, also wir sind ja UTC plus 1, ja, das war quasi 3 Minuten fertig bevor alles
ausgeholt war, das hier, exzellente, I created another app to revolutionize YouTube, ich bin
mir da nicht so sicher, ob das so ist, aha, irgendwelche Translation Geschichten, ok Leute,
das weiß ich nicht, ob ich mir das heut gebe, das ist der Typ mit 5 Kubernetes Clustern daheim,
wo ich mich immer frage, warum, was ist die Daseinsberechtigung, bei dem ist eine ganze
Technik daheim, make your home server go fast, SSD Caching, 10 Gigabit Networking, SSDs
und 10G, das ist tatsächlich eines der besten Sachen, die man machen kann, gerade SSDs,
ich mein, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei euch aussieht, wir haben ja die Zeiten schon fast
vergessen, wo es noch keine SSDs gab, also SSDs gibt es jetzt ja im Prinzip auch schon
die letzten 10 Jahre, also die letzten 10, vielleicht sogar noch ein Ticken länger,
die letzten 10 Jahre hatten die Rechner ja alle schon SSDs, sagen wir sogar eher die
letzten 13, 14 Jahre vielleicht schon, wir haben die Zeiten vergessen, wo es noch gar
keine SSDs gab, ich glaube ich habe noch nie von heute auf morgen eine so große gefühlte
Geschwindigkeitsverbesserung gehabt, in meinem Rechner als von Magnetfestplatte, als OS-Platte
auf eine SSD umzusteigen, also egal wie krass das Upgrade vom Rechner war, der Unterschied
zwischen Magnetfestplatte als OS-Disc versus SSD, das hat sich einfach in den ersten Sekunden
angefühlt, als ist das komplett andere Welt, das habe ich so noch nie erlebt, also der
Geschwindigkeitsboost von Magnetfestplatte zu SSD ist zwar nichts, was in Benchmarks
von dem Rechner jetzt irgendwie super krass auffällt, außer man macht halt IO Benchmarks,
aber gefühlte Geschwindigkeit ist einfach 10 mal schneller gewesen, äh, oh mann, was
soll das sein, Homelab-Tour, Alter warum Homelab-Touren die alle hier, ja das haben wir uns glaube
schon angeguckt, dass da Homelab-Toured wurde, oh guck mal mein eigenes Video, das muss ich
jetzt anklicken, das muss ich anklicken, zumindest, zumindest, ok wir lassen es, Viewtime
Leute, Viewtime, allerwichtigste, goodbye Raspberry Pi, ja aktuell ist das Problem,
dass man schlicht und ergreifend keine bekommt, ich glaube viele würden lieber weiterhin
Raspberry Pis verwenden, aber ihr habt ja keine Chance, wie siehts denn so aus, haben
die wieder welche, guck mal mal Geizhals, gibt's da, kann man wieder welche kaufen,
endlich Pi nachten, gibt's denn, gibt's denn wieder welche, Boards, Club Only, hey, ach
Moment, Raspberry Pi 2, Alter, was haben die denn hier ausgebuddelt, 8 Jahre alte Boards,
als es die neuen immer gibt, ja keine Chance, 4er gibt's einfach nicht, ja Kit ist immer
doof, du kriegst immer so viel Zeug, was du nicht brauchst, ich brauch kein SSD Card,
ich brauch kein Netzteil, guck mal mal, sind denn irgendwo welche lieferbar, ach ja tatsächlich
ergeblich lieferbar, wo, hier, und wo, ja ist klar, 143 Euro, ja ist klar, normalerweise
kostet glaube ich das 2 Gigabyte Modell kostet normalerweise 40 Euro oder sowas, sollte normalerweise
40 Euro kosten, ah hier 49, 143, die haben doch den Arsch offen mittlerweile, das, wisst
man, ne, woran liegt's eigentlich, können die nicht einfach mehr produzieren, just build
more, forehead, ich sehe nicht so viele gewachsen, verstehe, also ich bin ja froh, dass ich aktuell
keine kaufen muss, ich hab noch Raspberry 2, Raspberry Zero W2 hab ich noch hier, 1er
auch noch und noch 2 4er, also für alle Bastelprojekte hab ich echt hier, bin ich versorgt, moin
Marius, ich brauch erstmal keinen, ich bin froh, weil aktuell bekommst du schlicht und
ergreifend nichts an Raspberry Pi, du kannst hier nur, was immer geht, sind super überteuerte
Kits auf Amazon, die gibt es immer, 189 Euro man, normalerweise kostet das, was kostet
die 8G Variante, 69, 79 oder so, ursprünglich, ja du kannst hier so super überteuerte Kits
kaufen, die gibt es immer irgendwie, guck mal, du kriegst halt unsinniges Zeug dabei, ne
Kabel, was du nicht brauchst, ne SD Karte, was du nicht brauchst, das Case kannst du
am ehesten gebrauchen, das Netzteil, falls du keins hast, aber da hab ich genug von, 295,
alter, was ist mit den China-Chinesen-Kits los, das ist halt auch richtig Kackehäuse,
was man nicht haben will, das beste Raspberry Pi Case ist immer noch, ups, das ist immer
noch das beste Raspberry Pi Case, das ist passiv gekühlt, indem es einfach das ganze
Gehäuse als Kühler benutzt, das ist das beste Case, finde ich, gibt es auch für den Zero,
kann man es brauchen für einen Dreier auch, das ist das beste Case, hab ich 3 Raspberry
Pies mit, also 2 Vierer und einen Dreier, beste Case, Pock Case, 2. Quartal 23 soll
es ordentlich Nachschub geben, sagt wer, die Raspberry Pi Leute selbst, oder wer sagt das,
weil 2. Quartal kann er im Prinzip Juni sein, Januar, Februar, März, April, Mai, Juni,
kann er theoretisch Ende Juni, Mitte Juni erst sein, also ein halbes Jahr hin, bis es
Raspberry Pies gibt, was sind denn, weil wir einfach einmal in der Woche, was sind denn
die GitHub Trends aktuell, nein das nicht, Trending, äh, hab's ja wieder gut versteckt,
Trending, this week, China-Chinesen-Zeug, was auch immer, alles klar, obviously, ich
hoffe euch ist klar was es macht, also ich finde es ist schon relativ offensichtlich,
äh, China-Chinesen-Zeug, oh diesmal.net C-Sharp-China-Chinesen-Zeug, hello, ok, alles klar, er darf natürlich
nicht fehlen, ok, aha.
Aha, nichts dabei, was ist das, tiniest x86 für den linux emulator, soll ich das emulieren
wenn ich ein x64 x8664 rechne habe ah ok das ist wenn man beispielsweise x86 software
auf armen oder so ausführen will svelte hat sterne bekommen zurecht beste neowin das ist
eine 3d trocker fernwehr und svelte geht ja ganz ehrlich so viel spannendes ist jetzt
da nicht dabei was schon king hazard need choking hazard was ist mal ach so ah warnung
dass man sich dran verschlucken könnte wenn man die wenn man den raspberry pi schluckt
oder einatmet ja ok chat jetzt wisst ihr auch bescheid atmet euren raspberry pi lieber
nicht ein amazon sagt dass wenn amazon das sagt das ist ja prinzipiell immer richtig
ja ok wir gucken uns mal an was gibt es auf youtube so spannend was haben wir denn was
haben wir denn last pass gehackt also das ist mein eigenes video nur läuft tatsächlich
ganz gut man sieht was was was so ist man ist noch nie auf vielleicht habe ich noch
nie an heilig abend ein video hochgeladen also das video hatte die ersten zwei stunden
mehr zuschauer als durchschnitt und danach so ab nachmittag abend wo die ganzen leute
weihnachten haben ist das instant runter getraubt hat keiner mehr geguckt also man hat es direkt
gesehen dass halt weihnachten an dem tag ist in den video stats ok was haben wir sonst
hier epic paying auch nee nee please hör mal auf eure smart home automation ja das
gucke ich immer gerne was die leute wieder gebastelt haben 32 minuten da haben wir was
zu tun haben wir sonst noch home lab server last pass was was hackt ach der mental outlaw
hat auch ein video zu gemacht ok ok da weiß ich schon wie das video läuft kann ich schon
gut vorstellen er wird wahrscheinlich erstmal wahrscheinlich wieder was ähnliches erzählen
wie ich dass es eine dumme idee ist cloud password manager zu verwenden wie war die
bescherung unspektakulär übrigens wisst ihr was mich bei meinem video wirklich wieder
schockiert hat wie viele leute diesen krempel immer noch sie schön reden und verteidigen
dass es ja gar nicht so schlimm ist und dass ihr anbieter sicherlich nichts verkehrt machen
wir zur in der cloud ist es nun mal sehr praktisch ja das macht es aber nicht sicher ist extrem
praktisch ist die bescherung war sehr unspektakulär also wenn ich mir das hier so angucke ok da
bin ich nicht deiner meinung das ist ja alles in ordnung da sage ich ja gar nichts dagegen
password manager sind immer noch wesentlich besser als das eigentlich das gleiche password
bei 50 accounts zu benutzen das stimmt aber keine cloud password manager ich habe viele
tabs offen der moment meint ich habe hier noch mehr tabs offen ich habe hier noch an
die habe ich keine tabs offen ich habe auch nicht wirklich viel bekommt es gibt auch
ist auch schwierig ganz ehrlich so am gewissen alter ist halt das ding wenn du ein job hast
und geld verdienst in der regel hat man die meisten sachen die man haben will halt schon
also es ist nicht so einfach zumindest erst jeder ist jeder meinung er redet sich das
hier finde ich komplett schön ja also man sollte keine das gleiche password bei 50 accounts
nutzen das ist das ist richtig aber man sollte halt seine password nicht in dem cloud password
managerland speichern das eine folgt jetzt ja nicht aus dem anderen und in der cloud
ist es nun mal sehr praktisch das stimmt es trotzdem keine bessere idee nur weil es praktisch
ist für den extremst unwahrscheinlichen fall der fall ist so unwahrscheinlich hat was man
jetzt bei last pass gesehen hat für den extremst unwahrscheinlichen fall dass doch mal bei
bitworn etc die verschlüsselte datenbank geleakt wird ja also wie unwahrscheinlich der fall
jetzt hat man jetzt ja hier gesehen bei last pass die verschlüsselte datenbank wurde geleakt
ist es mit einem master password unmöglich zu klacken das hängt von einem master password
ab und das hängt davon ab ob die das ordentlich verwenden also ich habe keine ahnung was die
software von last pass macht und ich glaube die meisten leute haben sich die software von
bitworn auch nicht angeguckt die sie verwenden ob die das ordentlich machen man würde ich
würde jetzt mal von ausgehen ist ich würde der bitworn mehr trauen weil es ist ein open
source projekt konnten sich mehr leute angucken aber es kann immer noch sein dass sie bei
der implementierung der verschlüsselung oder beim benutzen der ihrer verschlüsselungs
libraries mist gebaut haben und es gar nicht richtig verschlüsselt ist kann immer noch
sein dann hast du deinen zeug im internet und kannst easy entschlüsseln also und wenn
du ein scheiß master password hast ist es auch easy zu knacken und selbst wenn irgendwie
doch ein password rauskommt dann sind meine wichtigsten accounts zusätzlich mit zwei factor
authentifizierung gesichert das gibt mir genug ja die sind mit zwei factor authentifizierung
gesichert sehr schön und gut ich weiß aber nicht ob die existenz der zwei factor authentifizierung
das leaking eines passwords irgendwie nicht relevant macht also sprich nach der logik
könnte ich ja quasi alles was zwei factor authentifizierung geschützt ist mein password
ins internet stellen wisst ihr warum das zwei factor authentifizierung heißt das heißt
weil beide du brauchst zwei factoren ein geheimes password und noch eine sms oder eine
email oder den code sonst wie und wenn das password herausbekommt da ist es eine quasi
nur noch ein faktor authentifizierung wenn man die irgendwie oder aufzupassen ins internet
stellt also ja natürlich ist zwei factor authentifizierung sinnvoll als zusätzliche
sache sollte ein aber trotzdem nicht dazu verleiten einfach mal die password dazu liegen
zumal zumal man die zwei factor authentifizierung ja bei einigen diensten noch ausschalten
kann wieder und je nachdem wie das gemacht ist reicht es vielleicht schon wenn man zugriff
auf sein haupt email account hat also ich verstehe nicht warum sich das die leute so schön reden
in dem fall ich doch ich verstehe es weil sie das bequem finden und keinen bock haben was
anderes zu machen aber ich weiß nicht wie man sich nach dieser geschichte jetzt noch
einreden kann dass ein eigener anbieter sicherlich nie probleme hat oder probleme bekommen wird
zumal es gibt ja noch mehr probleme also die ich in dem video die ich in dem video gar
nicht angesprochen habe was ist also mal abgesehen von dem grundsätzlichen problem dass du
bei den meisten anbieter nicht weiß wie sie verschlüsseln sie sagen zwar gut wir benutzen
es 256 das ist kein ding das ist aktuell nach heutigen maßstab sicher wie sind zehn jahren
aussieht weiß man nicht man weiß aber nie ob sie das ordentlich verwenden ja welche
library verwenden sie machen sie was eigenes ist das richtig implementiert und was du auch
das habe ich im video gar nicht angesprochen was du auch nicht weißt ist ob zum beispiel
morgen den password manager den du benutzt inklusive aller user daten die dort bekannt
sind an china chinesen verkauft wird zum beispiel guckt euch opera an opera ist mittlerweile
auch in china chinesen browser oder du hast keine ahnung ob die firma nicht verkauft wird
die dein cloud password manager bereit stellt vielleicht an irgendeinem laden dem du nicht
so sehr vertraust aber dann haben die den kram halt schon kann doch sein dann weißt
du auch nicht ob die infrastruktur von denen sicher ist erinnert sich noch jemand an solar
winds erinnert erinnert sich noch dem an zufällig da dran wenn ich das richtig im hinterkopf
habe wurden dort über die software als wurde dort software updates ausgeliefert die ich
bin mir gar nicht sicher war das solar winds wo das mit dem software update war ja war
es ok also dort wurde manipulierte software updates ausgeliefert das kann dir bei deinem
password manager genauso passieren und dein password manager wird dann instant zu irgendeinem
keylogger oder einfach die datenbank wird gedampt und irgendwo hochgeladen sobald du
das master password einmal eingibst das ist auch eine gefahr die du hast bei solchen
geschichten deswegen das beste was du machen kannst ist dass du selbst in der hand hast
dass du entweder so eine offline software verwendet irgendwas wie keypass verwendest
oder dass du die irgendeinen selbst gehostetes bitworn verwendest wobei halt auch selbst
bei einem selbst gehosteten bitworn ist halt die frage traut man der software an sich in
dem fall würde ich sagen ist das schon ok weil ich meine das ist ein open source projekt
auf github und du kannst ja auch noch andere implementierungen benutzen dafür also da würde
ich sagen das ist ok aber ich glaube wirklich kontrolliert haben dass sie wenigsten weiterer
punkt ist das habe ich auch noch ganz kurz im video angesprochen weiterer punkte auch
ein bisschen problematisches selbst wenn der anbieter sagen wir mal bitworn zum beispiel
ja bitworn hat ja auf github ihre ganze ihre infrastruktur aber die software die sie als
backend und mobile und freundin ist ja alles open source was sie angeblich verwenden wenn
du bei ihnen halt den password manager service benutzt also man kann sich das angucken aber
niemand von uns kann überprüfen und das ist ja auch immer ein punkt der total oft vergessen
wird niemand kann überprüfen ob das was hier auf github als open source ja sich jeder angucken
kann auch wirklich das ist was bei denen läuft also ja guck mal hier gibt es den backend
server von denen als asp.net projekt oder wahrscheinlich ja schön weißt du aber dass
dieser server ist mit diesem source code der bei denen im backend wirklich verwendet wird
hast du doch keine ahnung woher willst du das wissen woher willst du wissen dass diese
mobile app exakt die ist solange du es nicht selbst kompiliert hast und selbst bei dir
laufen hast woher willst du wissen dass diese mobile app exakt die mobile app ist die es
im app store gibt wie gesagt ich will dir nichts unterstellen ich glaube dass denen
dass das das gleiche ist aber du kannst es nicht nachvollziehen du weißt das nicht das
ist ja auch das ist ja auch ein weiterer punkt deswegen ich verstehe es nicht ich verstehe
es einfach nicht wie die leute immer noch und es gab die letzten jahre über so viele
probleme bei cloud surfaces also es vergeht ja im prinzip eigentlich kein monat und keine
woche wo nicht irgendwo user daten account und sonst was geleakt werden von irgendwelchen
cloud surfaces teilweise auch von super privatsphäre haltigen sachen ich erinnere mal an den weiß
weiß cam hack wo die leute wo sie irgendwelche china chinesen dein schlafzimmer angucken
konnten oder die geschichte mit den weil das die schaumig kameras wo leute auf einmal fremde
fremde kamera feeds auf ihrem google google google google gerät gesehen haben also da
passiert laufend irgendwas deswegen kann ich das nicht verstehen wie leute sich das immer
noch ein jahr das ist eine gute idee weil es kann ihr bei key pass auch was passieren
keine frage ich meine wenn ich wenn ich key pass aufmach und ich habe irgendeinen keylogger
und ich habe irgendwelche viren trojaner bei mir auf dem rechner sobald ich key pass aufmache
mein master password eingeben dann können die im prinzip auch mehr oder weniger die
halbe datenbank dampen die im ram jetzt gerade entschlüsselt ist klar so wenn dein rechner
am arsch ist dann hast du halt gelitten aber der unterschied ist da kannst du halt was
dagegen machen und bist du im endeffekt auch für daten bist du auch selbst daran schuld
ja und dort wachst du auf und liest die news mein password store cloud anbieter wurde
heute nacht gehackt ja fuck ich habe meine ganzen krypto wallets oder was auch immer
verloren ja scheiße und jetzt das liegt halt nicht also ich mir geht es nicht in kopf
ich kann es nicht verstehen dass leute ihre passwörter also auch für alles wichtige wenn
man jetzt zum beispiel sagt hey ich habe so fünf sechs dienste die verwende ich überall
die verwende ich auf dem smartphone die verwende ich was weiß ich wenn ich wenn ich auf der
arbeit sitze will ich mich da mal einloggen die verwende ich irgendwie im urlaub dort
auf dem tablet also wenn man irgendwie so fünf sechs dienste da wo man sagt hey da
brauche ich die logins wirklich öfters überall dann kann man eben diese fünf sechs sachen
meinetwegen in den password safe reinschreiben mit dem man singt wenn man das wirklich braucht
ja dann sind die dinger halt weg wenn es da probleme gibt aber nicht alle 320 die man
sonst hat und die sache ist halt auch die man braucht die passwörter gar nicht überall
also wisst ihr wie ich das mache ich habe beispielsweise bei mir auf many scalable das
so eine tradings trading app und die ist mega nervig die lockt sich alle sechs wochen oder
so aus also du machst die app auf und dann sagt ja melden sie sich neu an was ich mache
ist ganz einfach ich gehe entweder an rechner macht man key pass auf und tippt ein password
alle sechs wochen einmal ein fertig oder ich speichere ihm dieses eine password im iphone
key safe dann habe ich halt ein password auf meinem gerät im key safe geschehen im system
password store gespeichert ok da habe ich mich dann aber explizit auch dafür entschieden
und nicht alle 424 20 passwords die ich sonst noch habe die die meisten jetzt mal ehrlich
muss man echt in sich gehen mich würde man echt des anwendungs wirklich das konkrete
anwendungsszenario der leute hier interessieren brauchen die wirklich alle ihre passwörter
immer zu jeder zeit verfügbar auf allen geräten ich behaupte nein das ist nicht so
du hast fünf sechs services lass es mal zehn services sein die du vielleicht brauchst
auf dem auf dem handy und die allermeisten dinge haben eine eigene app da lockst du dich
einmalig ein und dann ist gut dann man das password ist dann auch in irgendeiner form
auf dem gerät gespeichert oder irgendwelche sessions die man abziehen kann aber es ist
halt nicht alle passwörter permanent überall hin mein windows könnte auch manipuliert
sein ja natürlich ja ja ist doch so natürlich das ist ja das du musst der ganzen sache immer
misstrauisch gegenüberstehen klar kann er du kannst auch ein keylogger haben sicher ist
das nicht aber nur weil die eine sache nicht 100 prozent sicher ist heißt es ja nicht
dass ich jetzt alles andere total leichtsinnig machen sollte oder ich meine nur weil es nicht
sicher ist über die straße zu laufen so prinzipiell gucke ich trotzdem vorher links und rechts
ob es vielleicht da ein lkw gerade kommt also es kann immer was sein
ist man mit zwei faktor authentifizierung nicht auf der sicheren seite nö bist du nicht
du bist vielleicht prinzipiell nicht mehr über die gleichen angriff wie man so schön
angriff weg drohren also bist du vielleicht nicht über alle angriff wege nicht mehr so
anfällig wie vorher aber es gab schon genug probleme mit zwei faktor identifizierung also
ja prinzipiell ist es natürlich so du brauchst jetzt zwei sachen du brauchst ein password
und du brauchst irgendeinen zweiten faktor zusätzlich noch sms irgendeine tanne app codes
per e-mail was auch immer erste problem ist viele leute machen es aus bequemlichkeit zwei
faktor authentifizierung mit dem gleichen gerät zum beispiel die meisten password manager
bieten möglichkeiten an auch als authenticator app zu funktionieren dann hast du ein password
manager da ist ein passport drinne und der generiert für dich auch zwei faktor identifizierung
tokens das heißt dein passport safe weg beziehungsweise password safe geknackt zwei faktor identifizierung
auch im arsch weil zwei faktor identifizierung ist ja meistens äußerst billig gemacht die
ganzen authenticator apps funktionieren nach mehr oder weniger dem gleichen muster ihr
habt doch alle schon mal eine authentifizierung ist eine authenticator app eingerichtet nehmen
wir mal beispielsweise den microsoft authenticator oder den blizzard authenticator solche apps
solche apps die hat ja jeder schon mal irgendwie eingerichtet diese dinger funktionieren eigentlich
relativ einfach wenn ihr die einrichtet dann scannt ihr in der regel einen qr code oder
müsst irgendein initial code eingeben so und was in diesem qr code drinne steht kann sein
dass ich jetzt ein paar sache vergessen aber so im prinzip wenn ihr so eine authenticator
app einrichtet und diesen qr code scannt in diesem qr code steht folgendes drinne ein
gemeinsames base secret und ich glaube das verfahren was zum errechnen der codes verwendet
wird so das ist alles und anhand der aktuellen urzeit berechnet dann also der server gibt
euch den qr code zum initialen sünden mit der authenticator app das heißt eure authenticator
app und das server haben das gemeinsame base secret das kennt der server das kennt eure
authenticator app weil es im qr code übermittelt wurde und anhand der aktuellen urzeit leiten
die unabhängig voneinander euer eurer gültiges token ab also der server kennt das secret
eure app kennt das secret dann errechnet der server aus anhand der aktuellen urzeit plus
minus 30 sekunden oder so ein aktuelles gültiges token das gleiche macht eure app auch und
dann sagt der server gibt jetzt ein token ein und nachdem wir beide das gemeinsame base
secret kennen und beide anhand des gleichen algoritmus zur gleichen urzeit den token
errechnet kommt bei beiden unabhängig voneinander der gleiche token raus und dann gibst du den
token ein und der server sagt aha das token was du hast ist genau das token was ich auch
schon ausgerechnet habe dass du darfst das ist das wie solche authenticator apps funktionieren
deswegen ist das auch immer nur so so so ein rolling code der nur in 30 45 für eine minute
gültig ist und das was diese authenticator app macht können natürlich passport manager
ohne probleme auch machen habe ich sogar schon mal selbst programmiert so was bei mir auf
der arbeite wo ich aktuell arbeite haben wir einen spam anbieter der also der spam nicht
für uns der macht spam filter für uns und damit du dich da einloggen kannst musst du
zwei faktor identifizierung im web interface machen wir wollen aber automatisiert dort
ab und zu die ein oder anderen postfläche freigeben ist halt doof wenn du zwei faktor
identifizierung brauchst wie automatisierst du das weil näher wenn du was automatisieren
willst muss ich das im hintergrund ohne deinen zu tun einloggen können also easy was habe
ich gemacht wir haben neuen account angelegt dann wurde ein qr code generiert dann haben
wir das secret das secret aus diesem qr code ausgelesen und ich verwende eine dotnet zwei
faktor identifizierung oder eine dotnet otp token library gibt er das secret und anhand
der aktuellen uhrzeit errechnet es mir einen code also das gleiche was die authenticator
ist ja kein häxenwerk das gleiche was so eine authenticator app auf dem handy macht kannst
du auch selbst in deiner eigenen anwendung machen so und wenn die leute jetzt auf die
glorreiche idee kommen weil es ist ja einfacher die token generierung und ihr password bei
in ihrem password manager zu speichern dann bist du halt gefickt sobald der password manager
geleakt ist beziehungsweise bald dort sicherheitsprobleme gibt weil dann hast du das password du hast
das secret und du hast das verfahren wieder die one time tokens generiert das heißt das
ist dann aus bequemlichkeit wie das gleiche problem password datenbank geleakt darin befindet
sich quasi alles was du brauchst um deine zwei fakte identifizierung zu umgehen wenn
du so benutzt aus bequemlichkeit was ich mir durchaus vorstellen kann dass es viele leute
machen so der nächste punkt ist was jetzt auch schon öfters vorgekommen ist bei zwei
fakte identifizierung die beispielsweise über telefon geht oder über sms geht das angreifer
einfach so lang genervt haben bis die leute keinen bock mehr haben zum beispiel ich überlege
gerade was das war das ist noch gar nicht lange her 1 2 monate da seht ihr mal dass
du kannst den kram gar nicht mehr an zwei händen abzählen was die letzten monate über
schon passiert ist vielleicht hat einer von euch noch im hinterkopf was das gewesen ist
welcher ich glaube da habe ich da nicht so gerne ein video zugemacht moment was könnten
das gewesen sein last pass ist es nicht ist es auch nicht war das uber uber ja das war
uber genau das hier 18 jahre uber trotz zwei fakte identifizierung login also eines der
sachen was dort wohl passiert ist der angreifer hat account credentials herausgefunden also
username password wollte sich einloggen der account war aber zwei fakte identifizierung
geschützt was hat er gemacht er hat sich einfach 870 millionen mal versucht einzuloggen
und jedes mal wurde der typ angerufen und irgendwann nachts um 3 uhr 45 ist der typ
halt als handy gegangen hat die zwei fakte identifizierung bestätigt indem er raute
gedrückt hat weil es ihm auf den sack ging dass er nachts die ganze zeit angerufen wird
ist es auch schon öfters mal vorgekommen so nachdem man mit spam die leute einfach so
lang voll bis sie halt zwei fakte identifizierung annehmen also im prinzip macht zwei fakte
identifizierung schon sinnvoller sehr sicherer aber so ganz und durchdringbar ist das auch
nicht genau es haben auch viele leute backup codes für zwei fakte identifizierung im password
manager stehen und das ist realistisch weil die leute argumentieren hier immer zu 90 prozent
mit es ist halt praktisch und es ist bequem und jemand der ein cloud password manager
verwendet weil es praktisch oder bequem ist der macht auch seine zwei fakte identifizierung
seine authentificator geschichte da drüber oder speichert auch backup codes da drin weil
warum sollte er nicht wenn er es doch aus bequemlichkeitsgründen verwendet der geht
dann bestimmt nicht an den schrank und holt seine codes raus die sind auch da drin gespeichert
was wäre ein sinnvolles vorgehen einfach kein cloud password manager verwenden da bist
du zwar auch nicht hundertprozentig sicher weil du kannst dir immer noch irgendwelche
melo ja auf deinem rechner einfangen die dann dein password dein master key mitschneidet
und was auch immer klare probleme hast du immer aber kein cloud password manager verwenden
cloud password manager sind die dümmste idee ever und ich habe keine ahnung warum die
leute immer noch cloud password manager verwenden weil du kannst natürlich beliebig übertreiben
ja du kannst auch drei fakte identifizierung wie julian bam hatte er nicht sogar acht
fakte autentifizierung oder irgendwie sowas oder fünf fakte autentifizierung oder irgendwas
in der richtung aber selbst das hilft dir natürlich nicht wenn irgendjemand deine cookies
aus seinem browser abzieht du kannst natürlich auch noch in den juby key verwenden als dritten
faktor wurde dann auf den stick drauf drauf oder auch noch in den autentifizierung stick
mit mit fingerabdruck was auch immer man kann das beliebig aufbohren ja und das bringt auch
meistens ein bisschen was aber dann sind wir wieder an dem punkt wie viele werden das machen
weil es ist halt einfach nervig und unbequem und gerade gerade wenn du es deinem handy verwenden
willst weil die leute sagen sie brauchen irgendwie ihre 420 passwörter alle auch jederzeit gesüngt
auf allen handys ja ich mein ist ist klar weil ich das login für meine hausratsversicherung
selbstverständlich gesüngt auf allen geräten jederzeit zur verfügung brauche logisch ja wer
wollte sich nicht schon mal spontan nachts wenn er offen wenn er sich besoffen hatten auf dem
rückweg in der s-bahn sitzt mal kurz bei seiner hausratsversicherung online vorbei gucken im
portal was er da für einen vertrag abgeschlossen hat immer immer also wer hat so nicht erlebt ja
was hältst du von einem selbst war das ist ok kann man machen ich persönlich bevorzuge
immer noch key pass einfach aus dem also hauptsächlich der grund weil ich key pass
seit 15 jahren oder so verwende und mich da dran gewöhnt habe ich gut mit klarkomme wenn man aber
was bisschen moderneres will mit mit webservice kann man auch ein selbst war das wird worden oder
wollt worden verwenden das ist auch ok muss man halt gucken dass sie nicht unbedingt jeder typ
aus dem gäste wähler dann da dran kommt aber kann man machen welcher das ist eine gute umfrage
das können wir machen hatten wir ich glaube die muss ich selbst wenn ich glaube wir haben noch
keine motz da um die Uhrzeit das machen wir mal also welchen pw manager benutzt ihr so da machen
wir jetzt als antwort textfile das war viel leute haben schon immer noch textfiles key pass last
pass one pass what was gibt es da sonst noch so n pass mehr kann man nicht eintragen also ich
habe jetzt key pass last pass one pass n pass wir sollten vielleicht bitte was was was ja ok
wir müssen wir müssen die umfrage wie ist diese umfragen seite die man die total viele leute
früher mal verwendet haben da gab es noch so eine das da ok type your question hier welchen
pw manager benutzt ihr also option textfile key pass last pass one pass words bit one cloud
n pass lokal self-hosted ja nennen wir es mal lokal self-hosted offline quasi wir nennen es
einfach nur ja so habe ich noch was vergessen ja papier zettel ok multiple choice soll ich
soll ich einschalten dass man mehrere optionen verwenden kann weil es könnte ja durchaus sein
dass jemand sagt ich verwenden textfile aber habe auch ein last pass wir machen wir machen
allow multiple one vote per ip address ist ok ja leute klar namenpflicht klar namenpflicht ok
ergebnisse live ergebnisse was auf der steintafel das ist quasi gleich wie zettel und papier immer
schön mit mit maisel daneben ein last pass user hat jetzt probleme man muss aber auch sagen wir
sind hier nicht repräsentativ für die meisten leute ja also hier sind ja zu 80 prozent technisch
interessierte das heißt ich dachte schon fast dass die meisten key pass und self-hosted verwenden
zettel und papier auch self-hosted giga chats ja also denke können wir sagen key pass self-hosted
zettel und papier sind sehr ziemlich gleich auf bit one in der cloud ist auch noch ganz gut
dabei textfile one password in pass also einige sind tatsächlich in der cloud ok aber es kann
ja durchaus sein dass leute beispielsweise sowas hier verwenden aber zusätzlich sowas
multiple choice also in die multiple antworten war nicht erlaubt interessant excellent giga giga chat chats
ja last pass auch nicht das hat gewisse offline funktionalitäten aber das zähle ich unter cloud
also alles was cloud wirklich keiner zähle ich unter cloud ja interessante sache soll also was
gucken wir uns jetzt mal mit was fangen wir denn das heißt mal ich bräuchte was last pass
gag das kann ich mal zumachen also euer smart home animatik automation last pass
ne da haben wir uns jetzt lang genug darüber ausgelassen 20.000 pretzel die woche das verdient
ein backer meister wir kommen wir kommen smart automation automations mal an das gucke ich
immer gern habe ich meine musik wo sollte man am besten seine key pass datei aufbewahren das ist
die frage wieviel du das auf anderen geräten brauchst entweder kopierst du es auf windows share
kannst dir sünden über irgendein filesync am besten natürlich rein lokal und nicht zwangsläufig jetzt
unbedingt jetzt über google drive oder so du kannst aber auch einfach auf einem rechner haben
und wenn du den haupt desktop rechner hast wo du die sachen brauchst musst du auch gar
nicht sünden wenn es nicht notwendig ist du kannst auch wenn du ganz hardcore drauf bist
noch in den extra vera crypt container stecken oder so wobei das doppelt gemoppelt ist und
eigentlich nichts bringt weil die verschlüsselung von der key pass datei würde ich mir insoweit
schon drauf verlassen nicht soweit dass ich sie im internet verteilen würde aber lokal erst
mal schon und wenn man die in den vera crypt volume hängt dann ist das eh entsperrt weil
man es ja benutzen will und wenn man dann irgendein virus hat kann er genauso also bringt es nicht
bringt sich wirklich kannst aber auch auf den usb stick zum beispiel packen was gar keine so
doofe idee ist auf den usb stick zu packen weil dann ist es halt nicht im rechner verfügbar
solltest du dir mal irgendwie also solltest du dir wirklich in den virus einfangen oder
usb stick hängt halt nicht am rechner da kann es das ding auch keine abziehen sobald
du es natürlich in usb stick rein steckst dein master password eingibst und keylogger
sein ist auch vorbei oder irgendein software hast du dann die im ram entschlüsselten password
da hochlädt auf iranischen server oder china chinesen server oder iranische server sind
mittlerweile auch relativ beliebt habe ich gehört letztens was drüber gelesen dass wohl
gerade vpn iranische vpn recht beliebt sein sollen in hacker kreisen die müssen auch
gucken wie sie an ihr geld kommen also tja usb stick ist gar nicht so blöd ganz ehrlich
ich habe es bei mir auf der verschlüsselten platte liegen das habe ich schon mal gesehen
ja ich habe es bei mir auf meiner verschlüsselten platte liegen das natürlich entsperrt wenn
der rechner an ist wie sollte es auch anders sein ich muss mit dem rechner hier arbeiten
also gucken wir uns mal ein bisschen heim automatisierung an neue inspiration für 2023
holen mir fällt auf dass ein weihnachtspulli hat aber ich glaube nicht dass er das meint
genau ich habe neue kopfhörer die man nicht so richtig sieht von vorne ist das nicht ein
fantastisches upgrade heute schauen wir uns zum letzten mal eure smart automation an lassen
uns inspirieren hey das hat er geklaut von mir das sieht aus wie bei mir im keller hey das
ist meins das ist genau das habe ich bei mir auch im keller wir haben sogar im stream teilweise
angefangen zusammenzubauen genauso genauso sieht das bei mir auch im keller aus nur nicht
so schön beleuchtet muss ich sagen ich habe das fürs ventil für die heizung meine heizung
verliert ab und zu mal ein bisschen druck da muss ich so einmal alle zwei drei monate
oder so muss ich ein bisschen bisschen wasser nachfüllen ein smarter smarter wasser wasser
druck haben ja lassen uns inspirieren schreiben die hausaufgaben ab oder erklären uns gegenseitig
für verrückt es geht um möglichkeiten des energiesparen das arbeiten am computer also
energiesparen da habe ich also meine zweifel ja theoretisch gibt es im smart home potential
energie einzusparen aber meistens sind die aufwände dafür so hoch dass man eigentlich
nie wirklich was spart also zum beispiel was man natürlich machen kann ist zu sagen hey
ich verbrauche meine heizung ist zu oft an so und dann kaufe ich mir smart fritz heizungsthermostate
für 60 euro das stück und klebt das an an die vier fünf wichtigsten heizkörper dran
ja das wird wahrscheinlich unterm strich am ende des jahres ein bisschen geld sparen
ja zum beispiel macht man sie abends vergisst man sie nicht auszumachen morgens macht man
sie beispielsweise nur auf die temperatur wo es sein muss wenn man auf die arbeit fährt
dass es nicht was auch immer so das wird unterm strich vielleicht ein bisschen geld sparen
aber bis man das geld eingespart hat was man für die 300 euro insgesamt kosten für
die thermostate bis man das eingespart hat das wird man wahrscheinlich zu lebzeiten der
thermostate nicht mehr erleben also die thermostate sind wahrscheinlich kaputt bevor sie sich
rentiert haben also das ist so eine sache mit vielleicht lohnt sich nach zehn jahren
oder so ja also da rein zum energiesparen glaube ich bringt das meistens nix es ist
eher angenehme sache dass du keine heizung machen muss ich habe sie ja hier beispielsweise
im arbeitszimmer auch ein da steht jetzt drauf 23 grad und der macht jetzt 23 grad wobei
es nicht wirklich 23 grad ist glaube ich 21 gerade ist zumindest auf 23 grad eingestellt
23 grad an diesem thermostat heißt nicht dass es auch im letzten winkel wirklich 23 grad
ist wie möglich zu gestalten die automatische fernsteuerung von hühnern zuletzt zwei auf
völlig unterschiedliche art smarte spiegel menschentiere ausgabe 16 hereinspaziert zum
letzten mal jep chicken ich gucke heute noch mehr mit dem adlerauge hin ich muss ja gucken
was wir fürs neue haus vielleicht übernehmen können und darum gehen wir jetzt direkt ganz
tief rein in die haussteuerung das gelogen das würde mehr konzept unterstellen als ich hier
aufzuweisen habe das war nur einfach der erste link smarte warmwasserunwälzpumpen regelung heißt
das video von manuel smarte warmwasser umwälzpumpen regelung das ist das ist bestimmt das was ich
bei mir so was ähnliches im keller schauen wir uns mal an wie so ein warmwasser kreis
erklärung im technikraum steht irgendwo die warmwasseraufbereitung quasi ein gut isolierter
tank von da aus geht der zulauf einmal durchs ganze haus jetzt mal angenommen ich drehe am
spülbecken in der küche das warme wasser auf jetzt geht das heiße wasser auf seine reise und ich
kriege am spülbecken erst mal nur das ganze kalte wasser ab das noch in der leitung steht hier kommt
die umwälzpumpe ins spiel hängt die an einer steckdose pumpt sie konstant heißes wasser durch
den kompletten kreislauf wenn ich dann irgendwo im haus den wasser an aufdrehe ist es sofort heiß
durft nur die langen leitungen verlieren deutlich mehr wärme als der isolierte tank und die heizung
läuft dann fast durchgehend um das auszugleichen und so super ist das für die pumpe sicherlich
auch nicht wenn die rund um die uhr läuft deswegen wird heutzutage ganz state of the art eine
neu modische zeitschaltuhr verwendet echt geil vor allem geht die dann mindestens das halbe jahr
falsch weil keiner an das teil denkt wenn die zeitungstellung ansteht mit der geht dann um
eine gewisse uhrzeit die umwälzpumpe so was habe ich übrigens meines wissens nach gar nicht ich
warte dann halt fünf sekunden bis warmes wasser da ist und tagsüber das ding dann meistens eh
durch also erstmal die drohe zeitschaltuhr raus durch eine smarte steckdose ersetzen da hat man
dann plötzlich deutlich mehr möglichkeiten und wenn es nur die synchronisation zu einem
zeitserver ist oder wochentags basierte programme uns reichen aber natürlich besser temperatursensor
wie heißen die dinge ds 28 10 oder so und der ist 12 10 was auch immer diese sensoren kann ich
wirklich empfehlen die sind wasserdicht und die kosten irgendwie ein noch weniger als 50
cent das stück oder so bei amazon diese temperatur sensoren deswegen messen wir zusätzlich die
wassertemperatur im zu und rücklauf und packen bewegungs melder in jeden raum mit warmwasser
ich habe zusätzlich gleich das ist aber das aber schon ein bisschen übertrieben oder wasserwärmepumpe
an den celli 1 p.m. mit temperatursensor add-on gehängt und damit auch messen zu können was
diese optimierung wirklich bringt so sieht das dann bei mir aus das kann man sicherlich schöner
machen aber für einen technikraum im keller passt das also nur dass ich jetzt verstehe die haben
der hat jetzt in jedem raum wo es warmwasser gibt ein bewegungssensor wenn der bewegungssensor
beispielsweise im bad erkennt bewegung dann läuft die umweltpumpe schon mal kurz anders falls man das
wasser anmacht im bad warmwasser direkt da ist was spricht dagegen zwei drei sekunden fünf sekunden
zu warten bis warmwasser aus dem wasserhahn kommt ich verstehe das problem gar nicht weil ehrlich
gesagt ich will meistens gar nicht warmwasser haben ich will meistens kaltes wasser haben
sei es um irgendwas zu trinken ich bin ja mittlerweile auf leitungswasser trinken
umgestiegen seit jahren schon trinke ich eigentlich nur leitungswasser und ansonsten
selbst so meine hände waschen war schnell nämlich kaltwasser also ansonsten so oft brauche ich gar
nicht warmwasser ich müsste gar nicht jedes mal warmwasser haben hast du deinen key pass
irgendwie gebackupt ja es ist lokal gebackupt und es ist auch gesunken zwischen meinen zwei
desktop rechnern den temperaturfühler für den rücklauf habe ich an ein metallventil zwischen
umweltpumpe und tank angebracht den zulauffühler direkt an die metallmutter des zulaufs am tank
die umweltpumpe steckt dann in einem schelle plug s der schelle 1bm mit temperatursensor
übrigens diese abzweigboxen sind richtig poc kosten auch nur ein euro oder so bei amazon
kannst du den 15er pack kaufen sind von ip 54 bis glaube ich ip 68 oder so gibt so was in der
richtung und die sind auch für kleine projekte äußerst praktisch du kriegst easy kabel rein
und raus du kriegst auch easy so durchführungs frag mich nicht wie das heißt so wasserdichte
durchführungs stecker keine ahnung wie da der richtige name für ist schraubst du auf
beiden seiten zusammen mit einer dichtung dazwischen kriegst du da auch gut durch kannst
auch gut buttons und knöpfe durchmachen hier oben das plastik kannst du beispielsweise super
easy mit nem kegel oder ein stufenbohrer mit nem stufenbohrer ein loch rein machen und
beispielsweise oben hier richtig schick nen knopf drauf machen und so was also die box
die sind wirklich sehr praktisch für alle möglichen bastelprojekte ist in der aufputzdose
daneben wichtiger hinweis noch bei dieser smarten regelung hilft es wenn man die umwelts pumpe auf
eine hohe stufe stellt damit der kreislauf schnell auf solte ja nehmt gebracht werden
kann bei mir habe ich drei verschiedene regelstufen stufe 1 wird aktiv wenn eine
bewegung in einem raum mit warmwasser registriert das ist ja high IQ shit bis der rücklauf 80
prozent der zulauf temperatur hat die 80 was ok lässt die pumpe solang laufen bis das wasser
was er überprüft die 80 prozent der zieltemperatur quasi erreicht hat oder alter das ist ja high IQ
automatisierung bewährt ist die temperatur erreicht schaltet die pumpe auch wieder ab wenn ich jetzt
irgendwo den han aufdrehe kann ich davon ausgehen dass mein wasser mindestens die 80 prozent der
zulauf temperatur hat da die pumpe natürlich trotzdem ein paar sekunden braucht um einmal
den kompletten kreislauf umzuwälzen haben wir zusätzlich noch stufe 2 die ist optional und
nur für besonders ungeduldige wenn jemand zu hause ist bei uns läuft das über eine anwesenheitserkennung
über wlan dann wird bereits eine gewisse kundtemperatur von 65 alter was ein aufriss
mann also da war ich ok ihr wisst ich bin sehr der ganze sache sehr sehr zugetan also ich habe
bei mir auch sehr viel unsinnige sachen smart gemacht und mit technik ausgestattet aber das
ist mir zu also das bietet mir zu wenig für das was es was es an problemen machen kann oder an
an komplexität rein bringt gut mag sein ich habe keine probleme mit fünf sekunden zu warten bis
warmwasser rauskommt wenn man dann wie ein irrer ins bad stürmt und sofort duscht dann
kriegt man keinen kälteschock mehr wie gesagt rein man kann auch einfach die dusche anmachen
fünf sekunden warten bis das wasser warm ist mal die hand vorher drunter halten gucken ob
die temperatur in ordnung ist und dann drunter gehen also es zwingt einen keiner den han quasi
sich unter die dusche zu stellen und dann den han einzuschalten wenn man drunter steht stufe
3 tritt dann in kraft wenn niemand zu hause ist oder wir schlafen und wenn man es vergisst dann
erinnert ein sowieso das eiskalte wasser beim duschen recht schnell daran und der lernefekt
lässt dann auch nicht allzu lange auf sich warten was ist mit den leuten los halten nicht einfach
mal die hand und das wasser bevor sie sich drunter stellen so werden auch zirkus tier interessiert
umgesetzt habe ich das ganze mit lock zone sieht dann so aus aber ist eine total einfache logik
die man vermutlich über die schelle klaut oder alles klar umsetzen kann man sollte auch das
thema legionellen nicht vergessen ich habe dazu parallel noch einen timer in der logik der alle
24 stunden eine viertel stunde lang die pumpe laufen lässt wenn man längere legionellen das
sind irgendwelche bakterien im wasser zeit nicht zu Hause ist hintergrund ist einfach dass man
stehendes warmes wasser vermeiden sollte die optimierung der warmwasser umwälzpumpe ist alles
in allem keine spielerei sondern spart wasser und vor allem energie bei uns hat das den stromverbrauch
der wärmepumpe um ungefähr 30 prozent reduziert ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen dass es was
bringt aber wie gesagt also fünf sekunden warten bis war im wasser da ist es auch okay noch die
optionale komfort stufe 2 aktiv haben ja ja ja sehr cool mal gut klar kannst du sagen durch die
fünf sekunden verschwendest du ja wasser was so nicht brauche ich glaube nicht dass ich das
ausgleichen ob du tatsächlich die pumpe schonest wenn du die häufiger eine ausschalten möre an und
abschalten da habe ich auch mal eine zweifel aber das weiß ich nicht ja hier eine sich habe ich
mich auch gefragt habe ich mich auch gefragt weil die pumpen sind ja wahrscheinlich für 24 7 ausgelegt
und es ist ein bisschen als denke ich mir jetzt einfach so ein bisschen so wie wenn ich vergleiche
so desktop festplatte versus nass festplatte oder storage festplatte die einen sind dafür gedacht
24 7 zu laufen und mögen es eigentlich nicht so oft einen ausgeschaltet zu werden und die anderen
mögen es nicht so 24 7 zu laufen für heiße luft aber pumpen techniker aller welt vereinigt euch in
den kommentaren und klärt uns auf und ich dachte erst du sprichst von der von der umwelt pumpe aber
du sprichst ja dann wären 30 prozent ein bisschen wenig aber du sprichst ja tatsächlich von deiner
wärmepumpe weil die dann weniger anspringen muss also da ist 30 prozent natürlich eine hausnummer
also 30 prozent ist natürlich keine hausnummer aber es lohnt sich auf jeden fall mal ganz abgesehen
davon dass du ein schönes projekt hat ist das zu basteln finde ich gut und eine deutliche einsparung
ohne so richtigen komfortverlust würde ich sagen also und wenn ihr wollt dass dieses format auch im
nächsten jahren eine neue runde geht dann stürzt euch auf zeug.cool zeigen ich habe zwar noch ein
paar einsendungen im köcher und ich habe auch diesmal noch ein paar eingebaut die mir so über
das jahr durch die lappen gegangen sind aber schick mir gerne deine automation oder kleine optimierung
jetzt erzählt er dass es ein amazon gutschein gibt oder sowas wir haben auch durchaus schon
wie so 15 sekunden videos gezeigt und für alles was ich zeige gibt es dann einen 50 euro amazon
gutschein den bekommt auch david für was auch immer er gebaut hat also sein telegram einkaufsport wenn
es den schnitt überlebt.ot ich habe pro zur einkaufsliste hinzugefügt nice und jetzt
wissen wir schon dass es home assistant war oder ist es nur die? ja es sieht aus wie home assistant
im hintergrund hat er schon recht also das ganze ist realisiert über einen telegram bot den ich
mir hier in einem home assistant.ich glaube das ist so ziemlich die umständlichste art und weis
eine einkaufsliste zu füllen die ich mir vorstellen kann.gebaut habe und das heißt ich kann mit
home assistant automationen darauf zugreifen die hat eine relativ einfache automation.telegram zone
trigger das heißt wenn mein handy die location einkaufen zone betritt dann wird das einkaufen
zone der Lidl oder? wenn ich da jetzt auf ausführen drücke dann kriege ich hier zack die
einkaufsliste auf das handy geschickt das passiert immer wenn ich in der nähe von meinem lieblings
einkaufsgeschäft bin.find ich ganz gut also das.by the way die idee hatte ich auch schon mal was mit
einkaufsliste zu machen aber wisst ihr was deutlich einfacher ist notizen und selbst wenn man mit
mehreren leuten im haushalt einträge vornimmt in dieser liste schert man halt ein dokument dafür
sogar das kann man wenn man es nicht in der cloud machen will lokal machen oder man trägt direkt
im home assistant ein wenn man daheim ist ja also ich wüsste jetzt nicht warum ich es brauchen würde
aber letztendlich so unsinnig mir das erscheint heißt es nicht dass es für ihn das erstellt hat
unsinnig ist weil er hat vielleicht ganz andere anforderungen und wünsche da dran als das was
ich mir da jetzt vorstelle das kann für ihn durchaus sinnvoll zu integrieren ich meine das
sind funktionen die so einkaufslisten apps auch haben dass man so eine liste pflegt und dann im
nachhinein erinnert wird wenn man wenn man da ist aber das ganze über den home assistant zu
machen ich meine es ist eine hohe assistenz in diesem fall woher weiß sein home assistant
eigentlich dass er gerade die einkaufszone im lidl betreten hat das heißt entweder ist das
ding von außen per vpn erreichbar er hat eine presence detection die über einen cloud service
geht oder einfach wenn die home assistant cloud eins davon muss es sein bestellungen entgegen
zu nehmen und dich im richtigen moment daran zu erinnern und das sind alles zu integrieren
dass im zweifel auch per sprachsteuerung dann machen zu können oder hier eben mit dem telegram
chat finde ich gut man muss ja nichts vorgefertigtes nehmen man kann sich da auch selber was genau auf
ein selbst zurechtpasst verwendet jemand von euch die lidl plus app soll random random frage
zwischendurch wenn jemand wie ein also lohnt sich das in form von schneller bezahlen genau
in der lidl plus also man kann wohl bei lidl an der kasse mittlerweile rein mit app bezahlen
lidl plus ich habe letztens gesehen dass irgendein typ vor mir an der kasse einfach sein handy
dran gehalten hat und der musste dann keine karte kein geld sonst wieder konnte einfach konnte
einfach quasi das bestätigen noch mal beim kassierer dass er mit app bezahlen will und
dann wurde das ja wahrscheinlich abgebucht haben wir von van nessa eine shortcut automation
bekommen und schauen uns auf die mal aus der nähe ich habe mir ein boppala morning update
shortcut gebastelt und da wird erst das datum abgefragt und die uhrzeit falls ich den einfach
mittags laufen lassen möchte dass ich dann nicht gut morning zu hören bekommen das will
niemand der grund warum ich den überhaupt habe morning update current time to format ich mag diese
ganze shortcut geschichte von das ist das ist immer so umständlich mann ich habe damit auch
schon ich habe damit beispielsweise so eine mini sache wenn carplay connected und so was aber ich
finde das ist unglaublich umständlich klar die mussten quasi eine scripting umgebung irgendwie
in apple usability style ab reinkriegen aber ich bin shortcut zu unglaublich umständlich von der
bedienung her man merkt sie schon es ist alles auf englisch bis auf kalender und erinnerungs einträge
und dementsprechend ist es einfach mit dem haus in apple morning updating völlig utopisch da
zu verstehen genau den shortcut agenda hatte ich schon da werden wir einfach alle was das
shortcut genda was da los erinnerungen ausgespuckt sowohl die die anstehen ich glaube zwei tage
voraus und die die hätten schon lange erledigt werden soll ich habe jetzt mal ein paar rein dass
man das auch sieht dann das hier der text ist einfach ein translate mittel weil das natürlich
übersetzt werden muss hier wird dann die sprache angepasst manchmal sind auch noch mal andere
sprachen wie deutsch oder englisch vorhanden was macht das jetzt in den hauptsächlich in
den kalender ach so siri liest vor was man heute für termine hat und wie das wetter wird und so
ach so ok kann man machen benutzt jemand irgendwelche morning update siri sachen nicht
also was ich morgens mache ist gut home office ist easy da sitze ich am rechner ich gucke
irgendwann im laufe des vormittags mal irgendwie aufs aktuelle wetter für den tag das gucke ich
hauptsächlich aus dem grund weil ich wissen will ob ich mittags zum grund wandern wegfahre
oder hier irgendwo um die ecke laufen gehen oder dann gucke ich mal ein bisschen hacker news und
ein bisschen twitter und was so was so auf news seiten steht aber so ein morning update kalender
gucke ich aus prinzip eigentlich so gut wie gar nicht rein die wichtigen termine kriege
ich meistens 15 beziehungsweise 30 minuten vorher notification was ich halt reingucke ich gucke
schon ab und zu mal so die woche durch oder so ob da irgendwas wichtiges ist aber ich gucke
nicht jeden morgen in den kalender und und merke mir dann ok kann ja jeder machen wie er will dann
location und dann wird mir das hier auch gleich dann vorgesprochen von siri und am ende läuft
die tagesschau genau ich spiele die tagesschau jetzt geht es nicht die einsendung ist schon
ein bisschen zum glück zum glück ist es in celsius und nicht in fahrenheit und dann habe
ich noch ein fürs arbeiten das hört ja gar nicht mehr auf aber dieses das ist so umständlich das
mit shortcuts guckt euch das mal an dass hier diese fünf seiten scripts werden wahrscheinlich
in irgendeiner programmiersprache fünf zeilen also diese 50 zeilen hier sind wahrscheinlich
fünf zeilen ordentlich programmiersprache mit location abgefragt das hat mehr ok das stimmt
natürlich nicht weil dort sind ganz viele funktionen eingebaut wie htp message hat
ttp get request post das kann es natürlich nicht so einfach machen so diese diese blöcke
verwenden ist dann natürlich selbst auch schon ein bisschen aber die logik vom ablauf her ich
finde es einfach unglaublich umständlich dass jedes mal wenn ich was mit shortcuts machen muss
hat kein bock mehr gründe erst läuft dieser day or night shortcut den habe ich hauptsächlich
da drin dass es interessiert mich jetzt nicht so und kreit chill akustik das am meck mit der
location ja das wäre cool wenn es quasi an shortcuts scripts gebe was man am desktop im
editor schreiben kann und dann quasi pusht das wäre das wäre cool aber nope nope sowas
gibt es nicht du musst das im gui zusammenklicken einfach am desolaten zustand von shortcuts am meck
da funktioniert ja irgendwie nichts was für mich in so einer situation im zweifel sonst besser
funktioniert ist nur mal so was angemerkt android könnte man an der stelle auch verwendet mit
tasker oder sowas wobei hey ihr wisst dass ich auch iphone user bin ja und ich bleibe
wahrscheinlich auch in zukunft iphone user aber was automatisierungen angeht ist not even close was
du machen kannst zwischen ios und android automatisierungstechnisch ist android einfach
meilenweit besser und wird in zukunft auch besser bleiben weil du kannst unter android einfach
mehr machen was apple nicht möchte zum beispiel automatisch auf irgendwelche sachen reagieren
um alle im minutentakt oder so ja im minutentakt im hintergrund checken ob irgendwas ist kannst du
nicht machen mit apple funktioniert nicht der tasker android kein problem das liegt daran weil
apple nicht will dass sowas gemacht wird und das nicht support hat vor nachteil aber wenn
man es machen will ist automatisierungstechnisch android einfach meilenweit vorne frage des wifi
wenn es bei dir vor allem um bekannte locations an deinen beiden standorten sind dann könnte das
eine alternative sein aber schöne alltagshilfe hast du dir auf jeden fall gebaut und ich ich
mag sowas also auch diese morning shortcuts und die dann am lebenden objekt nach und nach rund
schleifen und sachen ändern und so ist eine nette sache danke so und dann haben wir von
noel eine automation ein ring user kommt mir auch nicht ins haus verlassen bekommen und schauen
da mal rein alles beginnt damit dass man den pin der alarmalage eingibt warum zeigst du den
was ok ring kommt mir nicht ins haus auf voice assistance stehe ich auch nicht so schon mal
kombination kannst du mich kannst du mich nicht inspirieren hier über wachung gestartet 12
kameras die überwachung ist nicht jetzt erst gestartet die überwachung ist permanent aktiv das
sagt er bloß nicht was denn heute los ich habe zwei smartphones ich habe 12 kameras aus meinem
bodenständigen publikum für ausfahrt geöffnet hier wird die wlan steckdose für den receiver
der kameras eingeschaltet das nuke schloss schließt hinter einem das ist auch was ich mag
auch keine smarten türschlösser ok das ist alles in kombination was was ich nicht mag alexa
automatische automatische türschlösser und was war das erste jahr ring ring geräte 12 kameras
aktiviert 12 kameras was ist denn heute los ich habe zwei smartphones ich habe 12 kameras also ich
habe lass mal überlegen wie viele kameras habe ich ich habe die klingel klingel hof torr ich habe
also klingel hof torr habe ich eine terrasse habe ich eine im flur habe ich eine und oben am
katzenklo habe ich überm katzenklo habe ich eine ja vier fünf fünf aber ich habe richtig billig
dinger aber auch mit custom firmen wir aus meinem bodenständigen publikum geworden für ausfahrt
geöffnet hier wird die wlan steckdose für den receiver der kameras was bei den schlössern
passiert wenn die batterie leer geht denn dann musst du wahrscheinlich per schlüssel aufschließen
das nuke schloss schließt hinter einem das hat aber kein schlüssel mehr dann habe ich keine
ahnung wie sich das verhält was krachbar ich gebe zu etwas unschöne konstruktion
switchport coole sache ohne mist switchport habe ich nicht mehr im einsatz switchport sind aber für
alle sachen die man nicht so einfach automatisieren kann und wo man am ende den knopf drücken muss
sind switchports nicht schlecht genau für so was zum beispiel wenn dein garagentor nicht
ordentlich ansteuerbar ist nur über so eine ferne bedienung dann machst du im switchport diese ich
gebe zu etwas unschöne konstruktion ja das ist gut das muss ich übrigens auch noch fertig
machen da sind die gleichen ne sind nicht die gleichen ich dachte erst sind die gleichen
antriebe wie ich habe aber anscheinend schon mit meiner automation ja vergiss mal eben die
automation kurz darüber reden wo du hier wohnst dass ich ja schon einigermaßen beneidenswert das
sieht das sieht vor allem ziemlich groß aus vielleicht hätte ich doch einfach zwölf kameras
um aus mehr zu gucken oder was ich damit ne das sind berge das glaube ich kein mehr oder das sind
irgendwelche berge bisschen entfernt wenn ich zurückkomme öffnet über geofence das tor
automatisch erneut die gesamte automation läuft über eine amazon alexa routine ab während das
zurückkommen ja rein über geosachen das tor auf und zu machen da habe ich so ein kleines da vor
dieser herausforderung stehe ich ja auch gerade ich bin noch unschlüssig ob ich das machen will
weil es kann ja mal sein dass du am haus vorbei fährst also zum beispiel ich war jetzt mittags
eine runde wandern und ich fahre heim und mir fällt ein ich muss noch schnell zum lidl da
könnte sein dass ja meinem haus vorbei fahrt zum lidl und dann will ich ja nicht dass in dem
moment das hof da aufgeht man kann das natürlich alles mit ein bisschen trick 17 ja verbessern
dass du zum beispiel sagen musst genau kannst du beispiel sekunden sagen
du kannst sagen du musst du musst hier quasi für mindestens 15 sekunden drin sein
wählen bluetooth reichweite ja bis wirklich explizit bluetooth und wählen erkannt wird
dauern also ich also ich tendiere aktuell dazu wie gesagt ich habe die ich habe die
antriebe noch nicht dran ich tendiere es aktuell so zu machen dass ich schlicht und greifend ein
button ins auto lege wo ich draufdrücken kann und dann geht's auf oder ich benutze kb und
registriere das tor als wie heißt das bei apple wie heißt wie heißt dieses apple smart home kit
ich registriere mein hau mein tor quasi über eine bridge als homekit button das könnte ich auch
machen da könnte ich auf dem display vom auto auf tor öffnen tippen oder ich mache es über
ein voice command ich drücke auf dem lenkrad auf die auf die voice command taste und sagt dann
hof tor öffnen über kp das würde auch funktionieren also rein mit geo bin ich noch skeptisch ob ich
das machen soll geofence weil man darf nicht vergessen gps backt auch manchmal ein bisschen
rum also es könnte schon durchaus sein dass wenn ich durch den tunnel fahre dass auf einmal der
meinung ist ich bin in meiner home zone oder so danke max für deine streams habe zwei monaten
krücken nach kniop angenehmer gemacht das ist schön dass ihr das geholfen hat ich hoffe mittlerweile
ist schon wieder besser aber dankeschön für den sub vier monate massive subscription prog
so zu sagen bisschen bisschen den anfang vergessen ich war ein bisschen von dem ausblick abgelenkt
so alles mit der alarm auslösen und dann mit geofence das tor aufmachen wenn man wieder zurück
kommt ja sehr schön und das mit dem tor ist auch eine sache die die mich grundsätzlich interessiert
weil wir im neuen haus auch so ein also nicht so ein tour und auch nicht vor der kulisse haben aber
wir haben ein tor das auch so öffnet und niemand möchte erst mit dem auto vorfahren aussteigen das
tor aufmachen ja also wo kommen wir denn dahin ist also nicht in diesem jahrtausend freund ja
genau in diesem aktuell mache ich das so deswegen habe ich mir auch zwei torantriebe besorgt die
müssen aber noch installiert werden frank hat etwas geschickt was video und ich würde sagen
wenn ich schon mal hier bin gucke ich mir doch das video für mich an ich möchte euch unsere
smarte glascheibe im bad vorstellen ziel war es das tageslicht vom bad auch in den das könnte
gefährlich werden wir waren ja kürzlich auf auf einer messe um uns ein paar sachen anzugucken
fürs neue haus irgendwie so eine baubmesse da hätte ich mich schon instant geleakt hier das
geschichte und da war so ein fenster dass man auf knopfdruck durchsichtig oder nicht durchsichtig
schalten kann es war aber auch achso ich dachte da war auf einmal jemand nackisches dahinter
eine smarte glascheibe installiert die sollten personen bad sich im bad befinden abgedunkelt
wird beziehungsweise und sobald ich das bad verlasse aber die scheibe wieder durchsichtig
ich simuliere euch das jetzt mal ich hatte überhaupt kein bock da nicht durchgucken zu
können auch doch nicht scheiße möglich so wird die scheibe durchsichtig und ich habe das tageslicht
automatisch im gang zur verfügung ja hier noch okay würde bei mir architektur technisch nicht
funktionieren und keinen sinn ergeben aber okay mal der blick ist nicht schlecht sobald ich den
gang betrete wird die scheibe durchsichtig das mal und hab dann eigentlich cool oder
wie das tageslicht was zum was ist das für einen super gestyltes bad und badewanne ich finde das
bad sieht nicht irgendwie einladend aus als möchte ich da baten baden dann einen schönen
blick das sieht eher aus wie so ein aliens untersuchen dich bad also ich weiß ich das
sieht irgendwie nicht angenehm aus bad so wie das tageslicht bei uns aber geschmack
das ist schon sehr nett und bei diesen waschbecken also ich weiß ich kann über alles meckern aber
ich habe es jetzt schon öfters erlebt bei waschbecken dass die wasserhähne sehr weit
hinten und teilweise auch komisch platziert sind so dass wenn du dann die hand drunter hältst und
die hand nicht exakt richtig hältst es rausspritzt dir auf die haus also ich bevorzuge weniger
stylish dafür praktisch also wenn du auf dem klo sitzt dann sollte die scheibe nicht durchsichtig
aus heiteren himmel die scheibe durchsichtig dieser stuhl dahinten oder der ist doch nicht
wirklich dafür gedacht um sich drauf zu setzen das ist doch reine reine optik mehr wie nur die
urzeit anzeigen weil vor allem im bad so ein feld wenn er dich da nass drauf setzt dann muss das
feld erst mal zwei wochen trocknen betrieb kann er auch ein timer steuern und der spiegel zählt
ich weiß nicht wozu ich den timer braucht vielleicht zum zähneputzen oder so aber keine
ahnung nette sache ich denke daran das rauszupieken finde ich auf jeden fall ganz gut also diese diese
glas schreibe die auf kommando transparent wird das ja schon irgendwie eine sache das hat was aber
das ist wahrscheinlich schweine teuer ja wo ich auf der einen seite nicht was kosten so was was
soll ich in der suchen überhaupt glas schreibe durchsichtig nähe nach was suche ich denn da
überhaupt ich weiß gar nicht wie das heißt durchsichtig und durchsichtig ja top schaltbares glas schalt
bar gibt es bei amazon ich schaltbares glas punkt.de
scheibe transparent wechselnd
ok ich weiß nicht was ich suchen muss
smart intelligente moment das heißt wirklich so
ach schaltbar wie schaltbare folie sichtschutz auf knopfdruck
ahja das ist eine folie das ist nicht das ok das ist nicht im glas das ist eine folie die man
drüber macht das heißt man braucht quasi schon eine glas tür und da würde man dann diese folie
drüber kleben ok es ist auf jeden fall besser als das ganze glas auszutauschen und die ganze tür
finde ich gar nicht so verkehrt ich wüsste zwar nicht wozu ich es brauche aber da kann man was
mit anfangen wenn es eine folie ist ganz verstehe wie das funktioniert und das für mich so ein
bisschen zauberreich ist ich habe auf anderen seite auch ein bisschen haben möchte so noch
ein frank noch ein spiegel schauen wir mal was einer so kann der ist auf den ersten blick erst
mal ein ganz normaler 50 mal 50 spiegel wenn ich etwas sage hey siri kleine tipp wenn ihr
jemanden besucht und dahin ein nuki an der tür und ihr seht ein 50 mal 50 ikea raum dann ist
es kein normaler spiegel dann startet in dem spiegel ein raspberry pi und ein 17 zoll display aus
einem alten notebook und zeigt mir dazu gleich spannende informationen an so direkt hinter
meinem spiegel versteckt aber wenn er eine minute braucht na ok auf dem spiegel kann ich
informationen aus smart mirror sachen finde ich total overrated ich weiß es ist eigentlich kaum
was dabei wo ich nicht gemerkt habe heute aber smart mirrors diese faszination erschließt sich
mir nicht genau das ist eines der beliebtesten projekte wenn ihr in smart home reddits rumguckt
jeder dritte post ist ein smart mirror zeigen lassen wie beispielsweise rss feeds wie news
ticker unten links habe ich über ein html weißt du warum weil du kannst doch einfach ein dashboard
tablet haben im flur wo du das mal schnell angucken kannst beim durchlaufen wozu brauche
ich das im spiegel im spiegel will ich mir spiegeln und außerdem ist die anzeige dann immer so ein
bisschen ein ding ja ok wenn es jetzt ein altes android tablet hier hinten ist und so war vielleicht
aber ansonsten hast du das problem wie kriegst du die daten rein und raus du musst dann schauen
wie steuerst du das an da ist ein tablet einfach deutlich angenehmer und auch immer aktuell weil
das ist im prinzip ein browser fenster was du auf hast ja der effekt sieht cool aus das stimmt
dann ein smart window funktioniert nicht du brauchst ja dahinter platz als window funktioniert das nicht
da muss ja was dahinter sein hinter dem fenster ist ja die außenwelt die abfahrten der nächsten
urin ist bahn station eingebunden habe ich alles am dashboard ist eigentlich auch immer noch so
ein bisschen mein traum ein spiegel im flur zu haben der irgendwie dann so die die bahn und
busverbindung anzeigt das war als wir so einfach in den tablet als dashboard in flur ich habe oben
eins unten eins im flur beste sache easy as fuck ist ein altes amazon fire hd 10 ist also auch
relativ großes display das zeigt in home assistant dashboard dass ich extra angelegt habe für die
tablets da ist wirklich nur minimale infos drauf da ist zum beispiel drauf pakete die ankommen
müllabfuhr autolade stand fenster vergesse am fenster auf und zu zu machen und ein zweites
tab für die kamera an der klingel und an der kamera am hoftor fertig und das schaltet auch
automatisch um normales tablet mit akku näher das ist schon angeschlossen an usb direkt daneben
ist nämlich meine tür gegen sprechanlage und durch den kanal durch diesen kabelschacht von der
tür gegen sprechanlage habe ich ein paar waren auch übrige waren auch übrige adern von diesem
kabel das benutze ich für 12 volt dc und in der tür gegen sprechanlage in diesem telefon ist
noch genug platz da habe ich einen 12 volt auf 5 volt dc konverter usb oder usb rauskommt und da
habe ich die tablets angeschlossen also sieht eigentlich relativ relativ gut passend wenig
kabelsalat aus das kommt dann quasi dort von unten aus dem keller noch ein kabel wo ich die
tablets mit strom versorgen kann und dann hängt im flur hängen die tablets oben eins im flur unten
eins im flur und das schaltet automatisch um wenn einer an der tür klingelt wenn einer an der tür
klingelt dann geht es halt auf das also das tab wo man die kamera sieht in stadt gewohnt haben
ja die raspberry pi das kannst du im raspberry pi machen die sind aber ein bisschen zu dick
also so ein firehardy-tablet ist halt sehr flach und ein raspberry pi display die sind halt recht
dick also die sind ja dafür gemacht dass die raspberry pi dahinter baust dann ist das ganze
schon mal relativ dick so ein tablet ist halt wirklich äußerst äußerst dünn natürlich noch
ein bisschen relevante da dann einfach sehen zu können wo müsste man jetzt hingehen wenn man
möglichst schnell in welche richtung will finde ich schon gut ich würde dann versuchen das ganze
auch so freigestellt hinzubekommen also auf dunklem hintergrund wie die anderen texte unten rechts
gibt es meinen aktuellen kalender und oben rechts die wettervorhersage es werden aber auch noch
einige andere datenquellen wie zum beispiel die verkehrslage auf vorgefertigte ruten möglich das
ganze läuft über die glänzer software mir und ist kostenlos als open source mir ich bin ein
großer fan der grundsätzlichen idee ich würde wahrscheinlich versuchen die ja man sp 32 ist
doof darauf kannst du kein browser laufen lassen in dem fall da musst du dich ja selbst um das was
auf dem display angezeigt wird kümmern ein richtig vollwertiges template hat den vorteil du machst
im browser auf und kannst dann den dashboard anzeigen da drauf und du musst nicht selbst die
oberfläche programmieren bitte ein bisschen freier zu halten ich meine das 17 zoll bildschirm war
das also dann ist es aber der war aus dem 17 zoll notebook das heißt du hast nur den entweder den
oberen oder den unteren bereich aber für mich ist es halt im spiegel also der sollte schon aus
einer primäraufgabe einen eines spiegels nachkommen und hier habe ich jetzt dann immer den qr code im
gesicht ist die frage vielleicht siehst du immer gut aus brauchst den spiegel gar nicht um zu
checken was bei dir so abgeht es ist auf jeden fall ein projekt dass ich mich irgendwann auch
noch mal heransetzen werde wirklich wahrscheinlich du hast sowas gebaut zeitmeier
ja
des bleist über dpi amras peripay blub blub blub blub blub
was bild also wo wo wo ist das das display
dass ihr das display
da kann ich mir jetzt nicht so wirklich was was vorstellen
das aus
ich habe keine ahnung was ich hier sehe wenn ich ehrlich bin so sieht das dann aus an das
und längst und längst display ja gut gut dann ist es nicht so dick weil du das unten drunter
irgendwo verstecken kannst vielleicht so dann haben wir felix er schickt eine manuelle
warmwasseranforderung und offenbar beteiligt seine heizung ebus open up mqtt tuja und home
assistant dann gucken wir mal an was er aus diesem bunten potpourri so gestrickt
auf zirka 55 grad erhitzt damit immer warmes wasser zum beispiel zum duschen da ist an
sonnigen tagen hilft da auch eine solare trinkwassererweimung auf dem dach mit so
dass wir die letzten zwei monate ganz ohne gasverbrauch ausgekommen sind aber spätestens
im herbst wird das nicht mehr möglich sein also ja wie ihr merkt ist das vielleicht schon
ein bisschen das video geschickt hat aus gegebenem anlass wollen wir unseren gasverbrauch reduzieren
unsere wolf gasheizung besitzt auch eine funktion zum einmaligen füllen des speichers mit warmem
wasser die per knopfdruck in der bedieneinheit ausgelöst werden kann obwohl die anlage über
eine schnittstelle namens ebus ausgelesen und gesteuert werden kann und so auch in
unserer automatisierung eingebunden ist ist leider gerade diese funktion auf dem bus nicht
verfügbar warum also weil die hersteller immer die leute abhacken wollen habe ich den eindruck
im kleinen gerät dass ich irgendwann mal bei kickstarter sagt doch so eine art switchbot
deswegen habe ich auch absichtlich als ladegerät für mein auto eins genommen was eine offene api
dokumentation hat so was gibt es tatsächlich also es gibt tatsächlich hersteller von wallboxen
auto ladegeräten die eine api haben die man ansprechen kann also ich habe einen go e charger
home fix heißt das ding glaube ich genau ich habe nicht die ganz neue ich habe die etwas ich
habe nicht also es ist eh kein unterschied zwischen denen außer dass glaube ich die farbe ein bisschen
anders ist also es ist nicht viel also ich habe den da das ding genau die haben da ab ja kann man
verwenden wenn man will habe ich nicht verwendet die haben irgendwo api docks ob hier was dann schon
zu drinnen steht die haben auch auf github was wo man gucken kann ja also kannst du das steuern
über http mqtt mod bus und es gibt verschiedene versionen die verbessern das auch ständig also
wenn man auf github guckt dann haben die irgendwo auch in kram stehen genau ja genau da steht was
man wie wo schicken muss das schöne ist dass es schon fertige libraries dafür gibt und es gibt
eine fix und fertige home assistant integration wo man gar nichts mehr selber machen muss also man
muss dann die regeln selber erstellen was man mit den daten macht aber kommt easy da dran das war
für mich wichtig deswegen habe ich den genommen und nicht irgendwas anderes weil ich habe keinen
bock im endeffekt ladestation dann an der wand hängen zu haben wo ich nicht mit bekomme ob das
gerade geladen wird was es gerade verbraucht wie lange der letzte ladevorgang gedauert hat sind
ja alles infos die will ich haben und hätte ich mir in random station hingestellt dann hätte
ich wahrscheinlich wieder die klaut apis im zweifelsfall anzapfen müssen weil das mal
wieder in den hersteller klaut geht oder aber irgendwelche komischen modifikationen machen
deswegen habe ich direkt eine genommen die direkt spektakel sinnvoll abfragbar ist aber
ein sogenannter finger bot über das voice assistant oder das home assistant muss ich das
piepsen auf youtube lässt sich so jetzt schnell die zubereitung von warmwasser anfordern
ja bis die batterie leer ist aber die dinger sind echt praktisch ich habe auch zwei switch
bots habe ich aktuell nicht mehr im einsatz kommt aufs gleiche raus ja mit sport und der finger
bot aber von von der vom anwendungsszenario sind die dinger wirklich top wenn du halt was hast wo
du wirklich ein knopf drücken muss und es nicht anderweitig automatisiert bekommst sind die
wirklich nice wie lange hält die batterie ich kann es dir nicht sagen ich habe dir nicht so
lange im einsatz gehabt dass die batterie leer geworden ist mittlerweile liegen diese weile im
schrank und wahrscheinlich ist die batterie mittlerweile leer aber du kannst die batterie
wechseln also nicht so dass du neuen switch bot brauchst wenn die batterie leer ist ob wir das
wirklich den winter durchhalten warmes wasserhandel bei sonnenschein oder manuelle anforderung zu
erhalten wird sich allerdings noch zeigen zudem lassen sich aber durch smarte heizungsthermostate
und ein kritisches beobachten des verbrauchs unser gaszähler wird durch einen esb 32 chip mit
kamera ausgelesen da bin ich dass das steht bei mir auch noch offenprogramm noch eine ganze
reihe weitere einsparungen beim gas machen überwacht für die ganze zeit nicht per image
erkennung auslesen werde sondern ich habe nachgeguckt mein zähler hat wohl irgendwie
so einen kleinen magnet drinnen der mit rotiert und ich kann das mit einem kontakt an der seite
wohl auslesen jeden tick zum web dankeschön übrigens durch eine reihe von grafana des sports die
daten sind alle in einer influx db gespeichert mithilfe habe ich euch schon mal ein heizungs
dashboard gezeigt ich kann euch leider mein heizungs dashboard nicht mehr zeigen weil ich
abgeschaltet hat mittlerweile aber das war ja mal eine zeit lang running gag hier im stream dass
hier jedem stream ein heizungs dashboard gezeigt ich auch jahresübergreifende auswertungen machen
kann seit wir 2016 hier eingezogen sind ich kann nur jedem empfehlen so viele dieser daten wie
möglich zu erheben dass ich so optimierung wie zum beispiel in der heizkurve auf einer realistischen
grundlage heizkurve heizkurve musste ich auch einstellen weil der typ der angeblich super
krasse experte für diese heizung ist das ding einfach maßlos aufa aufa ja aufa tuner also über
überheizt hat also war richtig komplett für den arsch eingestellt wir hatten so oft probleme dass
sich die heizung automatisch abgeschaltet hat mit irgendeinem komischen fehler der typ
war ein paar mal da hat die heizung dann aufgemacht noch mal sauber noch mal neu hier und da und sonst
wieder hat nichts auf die reihe gekriegt alter was für unfähige leute wieder und im endeffekt was
musste man machen man musste sich das ganze selbst angucken ich bin dran mit einem raspberry pi hab
ausgelesen was der fehler ist habe festgestellt aha es ist brenner fehler e f1 oder sowas habe
ich mal am hersteller nachgeguckt was das bedeutet das bedeutet dass der brenner bzw das abgas vom
brenner überhitzt und sich not ausschaltet also bei irgendwie bei 100 vor allem ich 185 grad oder
was auch immer irgendwie schaltet sich das dann automatisch ab weil es zu heiß wird und das kann
entweder durch einen verdreckten abgas was auch immer des brenners irgendwie geträgte brennen
kammer wie auch immer es kann kann das ausgelöst werden was aber nicht sein kann es wurde alles
sauber gemacht oder aber und das ist das was ich dann durch rumgucken im internet rausgefunden
habe oder aber es ist furchtbar naheliegend der brenner ist einfach viel zu lang an für das was
er heizen muss also der brenner heizt wasser auf und das wasser wird dann abtransportiert und der
brenner heizt halt quasi das nächste wasser auf so wenn jetzt allerdings gar nicht so viel wasser
abtransportiert wird dann ist das wasser irgendwann heiß und der brenner heizt weiter und der brenner
schaltet sich irgendwann aus weil der brenner halt einfach viel zu hoch eingestellt ist also
was habe ich gemacht ich bin in die heizkurve rein und habe das einfach irgendwie um 40 prozent
runter geregelt und jetzt ist die heizung seit irgendwie drei jahren nicht einmal mehr not
ausgegangen und letztens war unser schornsteinfeger da oder hat zu mir gesagt ihre heizung ist aber
besonders gut eingestellt oder ihre heizung ist aber perfekt eingestellt da habe ich mir gedacht
er kriege also wenn sogar der schornsteinfeger sagt meine heizung ist top eingestellt dann kannst
du dir ja vorstellen was der typ vorher mit der heizung eingestellt hat easy clap also da frage
ich mir auch mal was manche experten da machen das natürlich schon ein bisschen hardcore also im
gegensatz zu manuel der nur seine pumpe steuert ist ein bisschen traurig dass eine funktion für
die extra ein knopf vorne eingebaut ist nicht über die apg oder nicht oder nicht über die
steuerung geht an dem gerät rechtfertigt dass die dann nicht über die schnittstelle angeboten
wird felix schreibt aber gerne in die kommentare ob ihr es jetzt im winter immer noch durchgehalten
habt aber ich finde das was du was du zum schluss gesagt hast ganz ganz spannend die genaue
überwachung dessen was man so verbraucht und das halte ich für ziemlich sinnvoll ich habe mich auch
mit ein paar anderen leuten ich könnte mir vorstellen dass es nicht über die schnittstelle angeboten
wird liegt daran dass die grundfunktion über die schnittstelle angeboten werden und dieser button
im prinzip nichts weiter macht als drei parameter an die steuerung zu senden die du halt über die
kund über die über den bus senden könntest schon aber halt nicht alle drei gleichzeitig auf einmal
sondern müsstest halt selbst was programmieren dann die lull dankeschön für den sab 42 monate
poggers so lang überleg ich das bewegte ja mal wie lange ich hier schon am start bin kommt mir
gar nicht so lang vor darüber ausgetauscht und das werden wir im neuen haus auf jeden fall auch
machen von anfang an also ab dem zeitpunkt der renovierung wenn da die neue heizung und alles
drin ist thomas schickt ein video stahlautomation tiere zack haben wir den namen des formats schon
mal voll mir völlig egal was in dem stahl drin ist das kommt ins video außer es kommen auch ein
anderes tier das beeindruckende ist nachdem meine meidens haustiere wollten und wegen meiner allergie
hund und kotz ausgefallen sind jetzt hat man hühner als haustiere top oder feder vier angeschafft
wobei wobei hühner tatsächlich sehr praktisch sind ich selbst habe keine hühner mein nachbar
hat aber hühner und wir kriegen ab und zu eier von den nachbars hühnern und wenn die wenn die
nachbarn in urlaub fahren gucke ich auch manchmal ein bisschen nach den hühnern und bringen den
insalat vorbei oder oder machen bisschen wasserein und sowas und also die hühnereier von den eigenen
hühnern schmecken doch besser als die hühnereier aus dem supermarkt und was ich gemerkt habe ist
ich mein hätte man sich eigentlich denken können aber hühner mögen das gar nicht so sehr wenn man
ihre eier wegnimmt wenn da nämlich einmal reingegangen und das eine hund normalerweise
rennen die weg also wenn du da reingehst in den stahl und willst ja dann dann flitzen die da raus
und sagen lass mich in ruhe und sonst verpissen sich aber das eine hund war äußerst hartnäckig
das saß auf dem ei drauf und wollte nicht runter und als ich dann dahin gegriffen hab
hat es nach mir so gehackt und gesagt gehst du weg von meinem ei wollte nicht
sind die eier zum essen nicht normalerweise nicht befruchtet richtig aber das heißt das huni ja
nicht die versuchen regelmäßig diese eier auszubrüten obwohl dann nie was rauskommt und das
huni hat sich halt gedacht diesmal diesmal brüte ich das ei aus und es saß dann auch die nächsten
paar tage noch drauf und irgendwann ist es halt auch schlecht um genau zu sein seidenhühner bzw
zwergseidenhühner die sehen aber schon sehr kuschelig aus deine zwergseidenhühner nachdem
wir von nachbarn ein altes spielhaus zur verfügung gestellt bekam wurde dieses neu gestrichen um zum
gartenhaus zu passen und zum stall umfunktioniert die voliere als freilauf welche kam dazu und der
passende übergang wurde angelegt nachdem die hühner schon eingezogen waren war nach zwei
weitere stufen geplant die erste war die auskleidung der wende und des bodens sodass eine gewisse
wärmedämmung bei geschlossenen fenster und tür vorhanden ist siehst du noch eine sache die
deine hühner und ich gemeinsam haben wir wollen unser neues zu hause denn bis zu diesem zeitpunkt
noch nichts was für deinen kanal interessant wäre ich auch dieses video gemacht habe die
automation des stalls gernstück ist ein raspberry pi jetzt die steuerung und kontrolle mit dabei
sind folgende aufgaben umgesetzt türöffnung und schließung beleuchtung im stall heizlampen ein
und ausschalten im winter hierfür ist ein bme 280 als temperatursensor mitgebaut und ein ventilator
ich muss mir das komplette konstrukt mal kurz anschauen also was hat er dann hier am start
ok heizlampe ventilator motor für die stalltür so da raspberry pi 4 b was wahrscheinlich
maßlost oversized ist für diese steuerung 99,999 prozent der rechenleistung von diesem
ding braucht das im leben nicht aber cool ich mein mal dass wir die firmen stahl immerhin
so dann hat er ein paar relays oder die leute legen ja hier wert drauf dass ich nicht relay
sein was soll ich sagen ich soll nicht relay sagen sondern relay oder so relay
da legt der chat wert drauf habe ich schon festgestellt das hättest du wahrscheinlich
sogar mit irgendeinem uralt arduino machen können ich so arduino uno von 2005 oder
hätte wahrscheinlich auch machen können aber idee zählt ja so nottaster ok alles klar so 5 volt
für was für die raspberry pi logischerweise weil usb 5 volt ok 12 von netzteil wahrscheinlich
weil dieses ganze zeug weil der motor 12 volt brauchen vielleicht auch die lampe so dann
eine 5 volt converter für den raspberry pi da muss er irgendwie laufen dann steuert er also
eigentlich steuert er mit dem raspberry pi nur in anführungsstrichen soweit ich das die relays die
relays die dann die lampe schalten beziehungsweise den motor und ich würde jetzt mal vermuten dass
der ventilator per pwm gesteuert wird über den raspberry pi weil ich das jetzt nicht so genau
sehe wo das kabel dahin geht nee nee nee das geht auch an das relay also im prinzip schalte
der raspberry pi wahrscheinlich wirklich nur diese paar relays das hätte man easy mit dem
uraltesten arduino machen können oder mit irgendeinem sp 2 866 sp 2 also im prinzip mit quasi
allem der raspberry pi 4 ist so krass oversized oversized kann es da eigentlich gar nicht mehr
sein hat aber auch seine vorteile er kann sich zum beispiel remote psh in seinem hühnerstall einloggen
und da dran am script basteln oder so also hat mein vollwertige linux rechner zu haben ist immer
schon nicht verkehrt aber trotzdem rechenleistung absolut oversized sensor mit verbaut und ein
ventilator der im sommer wenn es zu warm wird im stahl luft zwölf lüfter dann ist er nicht
am raspberry pi über relays die vom raspberry pi angesteuert werden vom stück sollte man im
dunkeln im stahl etwas kontrollieren wollen so kann man per taster die leds mit schwachen da bestimmt auch eine kamera die elektriker in den
kommentaren überschlagen sich vor begeisterung von einer installation so nicht schlimm für 30
sekunden und der taster geht danach wieder auf wartestellung bis zum nächsten auslösen und für
die kontrolle dass die hühner auch wirklich im stahl sind und alles passt ist im garten aus eine
bewachungskamera angebracht die die voliere behält falls noch fragen sind ihr den quellcode
brauchen könnt oder ihr wünschen und anregungen habt könnt ihr es gerne in die kommentare schreiben
und euch bei mir melden das hat ja schon so ein bisschen ein bisschen was bedrohliches wenn das
ding so runterfährt so ein bisschen independence day oder so sie versuchen noch aus dem alien
raumschiff auszubrechen oder irgendeine james bond verfolgungsjagd und er rutscht auf motorrad dann
noch unterdurch danke grüße an dich und deine seidenhühner die jetzt in einem sehr schön
automatisierten hühnerstall leben können brauchst du nicht mal irgendwie die nachbarn bitten da irgendwas
aufzumachen excellent high iq hühnerstall wahrscheinlich recht schnell dass sie wenn die
tür zugeht weggehen soll also spätestens das zweite uhr lernt das michael home assistant
raycast extension ich habe es jetzt circa eineinhalb jahren ein smart home mit karl nix phillips u und
diversen anderen herstellern das gesamte system wird über home assistant orchestriert dank deiner
zahlreichen videos kamen über die zeit immer mehr automatisierungen und geräte hinzu was die
verwaltbarkeit deutlich erschwerte ich habe nach einer es tut mir sehr leid michael lösung
gesucht dadurch habe ich nichts für mich passendes gibt es tut mir nicht wirklich leid und beschlossen
selbst eine lösung zu entwickeln da ich seit zwei jahren das produktivitäts tool raycast in einem
alltag sehr oft verwende habe ich eine extension für österreicher entwickelt raycast ist ein
meccas spotlights ersatz es kann mit einem simplen keyboard shortcut aktiviert werden und bietet also
im prinzip so was wie an die habe ich auch im prinzip so was wie keine ahnung rufi oder oder
wie heißt diese smart launcher zeug nur wahrscheinlich ein bisschen advanced oder mir allerhand befähle
durch das simple eintippen von texten ähnlich eines terminals home assistant hat die möglichkeit sich
selbst add ons oder externe geräte abzudaten was ein ziemlich praktisches feature ist da ich mich
nicht ständig in anderen geräte einloggen muss die verwaltung der updates fand ich aber im
dashboard sehr gut versteckt hierfür habe ich den command updates integriert dieser zeigt mir mit
einem shortcut beziehungsweise einmal eintippen des wortes update sofort an bei welchem gerät ein
update ansteht und ich kann mit einem simplen command das update starten ein weiterer befähigen
man könnte auch einfach ins web interface unter updates ich meine warum brauche ich das über den
lautscher ist cameras nicht ganz so hier bekomme ich eine übersicht all meiner kameras und kann mit
einem einfachen shortcut das bild auch in großer ok das ist auch nicht verkehrt aber ich kann auch
einfach das tab im browser aufmachen wo die kameras drin sind aber gut jeder wieder lassen
mit dem fall dass wieder jemand an der tür klingelt und ich nicht weiß wer vor der tür steht falls ich
am anderen ende des hauses bin ich versuche gerade das unscharfe durch zusammen knallen ist das der
ist das der schneemann von der eiskönigin mit der zeit bekommt man mehr und mehr smart home geräte
die mit batterien funktionieren wie zum beispiel akara bewegung sensoren die übersicht über all
die batterien geht schnell verloren deswegen habe ich den command batteries ja man könnte auch
einfach ins dashboard aber gut er möchte es halt unbedingt im lautscher haben akkustände die
batterien haben das ja fantastisch ich weiß nicht woher du das weißt oder wie das timing passt aber
ich bin vorletzte woche oder so von alfred auf raycast umgestiegen und ich werde jetzt glaube
ich mal bevor wir hier dein video weiter gucken werde ich mal eben das schon mal installieren
ist gekauft so jetzt kannst du das verkaufsgespräch weiter hier als nächstes das verwalten von
automatisierungen ist den home assistant sehr langsam und mit sehr vielen klicks verbunden
mit dem kastbefehl automations kann ich direkt nach der geeigneten automatisation suchen direkt
wir shortcut in home assistant aufmachen zum beispiel wenn ich nach meinen rollläden suche
kann ich hier zum beispiel die die automatisierung ein oder ausschalten wenn ich sie editieren möchte
drücke ich einfach nur command e ja das stimmt wobei home assistant ja mittlerweile auch die
möglichkeit hat so was im web interface zu suchen und wenn du auf der automation seite bist drückst
da einfach steuerung f und suchst da drinne also ich verstehe den den den charm seiner lösung
wenn er diesen launcher zum größten teil verwendet viel ersparts einem nicht ich kann meine
automatisation editieren wie ich möchte die home assistant extension für raycast besteht
mittlerweile aus 27 befehlen okay das ist eigentlich richtig high IQ dass er das eingeschickt hat und
am anfang denkst du so cool und dann merkst du eigentlich will er seine extension verkaufen
richtig high IQ move ringkant extinction den alltags stark erleichtern vielen dank ich bin
sehr gespannt das gleich im anschluss auszuprobieren den link zu raycast und auch zu michaels
erweiterung findet ihr wie auch die teile die die anderen so verwendet haben so fern ich sie
gefunden habe unten in der video beschreibung zusammen mit den ursprungs videos die ich ja
teilweise ein bisschen gekürzt was wären deine top raspberry pi projekte das müsste ich mir
erst mal gedanken drüber machen ich werde auch öfters im stream gefragt so was sind gute
programmierprojekte für einsteiger kann jemand so aus dem ermüll geschüttelt nicht sagen damit
wir hier auf den grünen zeig kommen ein video roll ansteuerung mit switchport geschickt ich bin
gespannt switchport die knöpfe gedrückt genau genau für so was ist switchport einfach top genau
für so was dinge die du nicht gescheit anderweitig automatisieren kannst einfach weil es klassische
knopf drücke druck braucht habe ich hier im schlafzimmer ein switchport an die ein klar
man könnte jetzt den schalter raus machen den esp drunter machen das irgendwie so aber so ist
wahrscheinlich einfacher elektrischen rolladen geklebt und der drückt dann jeden morgen pünktlich
um acht uhr die beiden schalter so hier zu sehen dass eben die rolladen hochfahren und dann kann ich
das mit einem switchport beide hochgefahren auf den einen ja das ist sehr clever das ist
richtig hrq guck mal physik und so eine gute lösung für alle die weche in einer mietwohnung
leben und da jetzt nicht die ganzen schalter austauschen wollen moment mal freundchen das
geht doch nur in eine richtung oder du kannst doch nicht der switchport kann sich ja nicht wieder
ranziehen victor zu der 50 euro erschlichen ich meine die andere richtung funktioniert
muss man abends wie ein tier eben drauf drücken naja gut dafür braucht man nur einen switchport so
marcus schickt seinen smarten wasserhahn ins rennen und den will ich natürlich auch sehen
drei stunden später diese diese das sind so programmierer antworten von von sirene ich
habe die anfrage abgeschickt ich habe nicht gemacht was du willst ich habe sie nur ausgelöst
ob es funktioniert interessiert mich das wird alles viel zu lange dauern da würde ich lieber
den knopf drehen ganz im ernst das wird mir das wird mir zu lange dauern das ist natürlich
überhaupt kein hexenberg und wie der zauberhahn funktioniert das schauen wir uns jetzt mal eine
etage tiefer an war ganz nach vorne abgesehen an sich ist es nicht verkehrt so was in seiner
heimautomatisierung einzubinden wenn man es sagen wir mal remote an und aus machen will wenn du
sicher gehen willst dass es aus ist wenn du reingehst ins haus kann man alles sinnvoll machen aber
gerade die sprachsteuerung weil sie nicht den gardener aufsatz tropft das macht mich ein
bisschen auch schon wieder so ein ding kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor der sommer war teuer ist
das gießen im garten mit frischwasser an bedarf und deswegen haben wir uns entschieden einmal
eine neue wasseruhr einzubauen um geld zu sparen und dazu musste die natürlich auch wie der rest des
hauses smart gestaltet werden hier war uns dieser smart controller geholfen der mit einfachen
mitteln ein motor und wlan anschluss und stromanschluss hier seine arbeit doch doch krasius
du musst ja am haren sein sonst versteht ich alexa ja gar nicht du kannst nicht deine 30 meter
schlauch haben im garten stehen und dann sagen hier alexa bitte den gartenhahn ein auslander
versteht ich ja gar nicht du musst schon daneben stehen oder du hast ein smartphone dabei ja genau
das ist oder du hast ein smartphone dabei und diktierst das dann so mit einer hand irgendwie oder keine
ahnung also wenn du die apple watch dabei ist okay leute ja meinetwegen es mag gehen aber ich
weiß nicht lang verrichtet wasserhahn garten ausschalten ja so sieht das bei mir im kerb auch aus
dass niemand in eurer abwesenheit den wasserhahn unberechtigt benutzen kann solange ihr einen
kugelhahn als absteller habt funktioniert das natürlich auch an der hauptwasserversorgung
wenn ihr zum beispiel im urlaub seid oder länger nicht zu hause das war es viel spaß beim nachbauen
ganz spannend dass wirklich mit einem harten ventil irgendwo innen im haus zu machen dann
ist der wasserhahn ja auch eher winterfest und sowas im zweifel dann auch wirklich an die
hauptwasserleitung zu setzen falls irgendwo ein leck sensor anschlägt kann ich so schlecht so noch
einmal der hinweis wenn euch das heute in irgendeiner form inspiriert hat wenn ihr
irgendwas zu hause habt und ihr habt eben heute hat es mich tatsächlich nicht so sehr inspiriert
dabei die vielleicht nur eine idee haben weil ich an dem meisten was zu meckern hatte und
nichts dabei war gesagt er hat ja das will ich nachbauen dann er geht auf zeug punkten
aber ansonsten ist die serie wirklich nice und wenn ich sie hier zeige gibt es 50 euro
aufwandsentschädigung in form eines gutscheins und jetzt bleibt mir nur zu sagen zu haben
die serie mag ich gucke ich mir immer gerne an das stimmt ja da hast du viele leute die
der meinung sind wenn sie jetzt kein knopf mehr drücken müssen und stattdessen einfach sagen
dass der knopf gedrückt werden soll wäre das irgendwie super smart es ist eigentlich eher
super umständlich viel besser ist wenn halt entweder das ganz automatisch passiert oder
nach einem voice command zusammenhängende sachen passieren also nicht nur der schalter gedrückt
wird sondern dann gleichermaßen also zum beispiel mal ein beispiel wenn man jetzt abends ins bett
geht dazu muss man licht ausschalten heizung runter drehen und sowas in der richtung wenn
man jetzt das von hand macht ist das eine wenn man jetzt das automatisierbar macht ist das andere
wenn ich jetzt ein sprachbefehl einbaue und sage und sagen muss alexa bitte keine heizung im
wohnzimmer runter drehen heizung im arbeitszimmer runter drehen licht aus im wohnzimmer licht aus
im arbeitszimmer im bad hier das ist blöd was besser ist ist zu sagen schlafmodus aktivieren
und dann macht er die sachen für dich das hat halt einen gewissen vorteil oder noch besser gar
nichts sagen müssen und das ding checkt automatisch wenn man schlafen geht aus
irgendeiner kombination von urzeit und handy lade dings im schlafzimmer oder vielleicht sogar
einen gewichtssensor am bett durch dann die premium variante was kannst du so empfehlen
es hängt es ist wirklich super individuell mir fällt da immer spontan nicht so viel ein
ich müsste echt mal ein bisschen smart home zeug zeigen habe ich auch schon mal gefragt
in dem video und alle haben gesagt ja zeigt mal das würde ich dann schon so auf drei videos
aufteilen ja immer mal so in jedem video so fünf minuten lang nehmen als drei vier sachen zeigen
gibt ja schon einiges ok was haben wir hier technik und der hat der typ hat bestimmt wieder
wie wir skippen das woran woran seine kubernetes cluster zeigt ich will mir einfach seinen rack
angucken die hälfte vom video können wir skippen wahrscheinlich das ist der kerl mit dem kubernetes
mit mit den fünf kubernetes cluster daheim und wo ich absolut keine ahnung habe warum er dieses
setup hat weil er hat 80 prozent seine infrastruktur um seine infrastruktur zu verwalten nicht um dafür
sinnvolle sachen zu finden wir sehen die new world spieler ok weil wir dabei sind wir gucken ja
ganz gerne mal also new battlefield ist wieder ist wieder daun ist wieder vorbei und das zu
weihnachten keckel alter leute und das zu weihnachten niemand niemand hat das game gespielt man ok das
ist das ist alles wieder daun und dann haben wir auch new world new world ist wahrscheinlich auch
f ja hier hatten sie ihre ihre season nämlich ihre season ihre neun neun server was natürlich
wieder viel angesprochen jetzt wieder jetzt wieder oder wundert mich nicht richtig verkackt
mal gucken das kann er machen aber ich skippen die hälfte jetzt sind es nicht mehr fünf kubernetes
cluster sind es acht kubernetes cluster ami wende leute ami wende das kannst du auch nur da machen
einfach mal mit der säge ein loch in die wand geschnitten diese diese perf bords dinger da die sind cool wenn man acht kubernetes cluster
an der heimat vielleicht wichtig wichtig das rack muss unbedingt eckig besiert sein
wichtig und richtig
erhebe documenting for posterity und jetzt ist time for an upgrade in 3 2 1
warum
ordentlich gemacht ist es
in 3 2 1
oh ja so hier ist mein new and improved homelab in my server room and over here
is a bunch of stuff that und 30 fps kameraufnahme
ist auch so ein ding da habe ich einen großen bogen drum gemacht
wie hat er den kabelbinder hier durchbekommen
das gemacht hat von hinten kommst ja nicht ran
wie laut sind kisten in so einem rack tue zu und nichts mehr zu hören nein also wenn das
ordentliche hardware ist die auch für regeisen rechenzentrum einsatz gedacht ist das hörst du
das ist ordentlich laut als beispiel noch mal blade center war das youtube video letztens dazu
das ist jetzt aber auch der extrem fallen das ist so ziemlich das lauteste was ich
kenne aus dem rechenzentrum seine kisten werden in der ecke leiser sein aber die sind nicht
dafür gedacht dass sie leise sind also je nachdem was er da drin hat aber die meisten
sind nicht dafür gebracht leise zu sein und rex haben in der regel auch weniger eine so
isolierende wirkung also das ist meistens halt einfach in metall gestellt ohne dass
es jetzt irgendwie groß für als schallschutz gedacht ist das wirst du auf jeden fall hören
die schauen immer so traurig die ami steckdosen
kann man doch machen ich meine die access point sind eigentlich für decken ding aber das ist egal
und geht genauso aber das ist irgendwelches unify machine zeug da oben wieder oder unify
hat sich bei mir erledigt das stimmt ja wenn es wirklich komplett zu ist so lang
dass wir keine keine löcher sind die klar wenn es zu ist macht es leiser aber trotzdem
da nehmen wir aber in willst du wahrscheinlich nicht 27 grad vollkommen im raum
die
Ok, also für meine Patch-Panels, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das in einem vorherigen Video gesehen habt, aber vor diesem Jahr habe ich meinen PoE-Switch aufgebildet, der im Mittelpunkt ist.
Ich hatte einen 24-Port, der jetzt da unten ist, der wird bald verwendet, aber ich habe ihn mit einem 48-Port PoE-Switch verwendet.
Und dieser ist ziemlich toll. Ich könnte es nicht nur so machen, dass ich 48-Ports habe, damit diese richtig auslösen können. Nein, das ist ein Lied.
Das hier hat 24-Ports, die alle PoE-Switch waren, also habe ich einen 48-Port PoE-Switch verwendet, damit ich keine PoE-Switch habe.
Wenn du nicht in der Fronten-Networking magst, wirst du viel mehr sehen, als du in der Fronten-Networking auch nicht magst.
So, das ist mein UDM-SE. Das ist nicht mein UDM-PRO. Ich habe den UDM-PRO zu einem Freund gekauft und den UDM-SE aufgebildet.
Ehrlich gesagt musste ich ihn nicht aufbauen. Es gibt noch ein paar PoE-Ports, die toll sind, aber ich wollte es mit dem Internet aufbauen, weil es 2,5 Gigabit auf dem WAN hat.
Nicht, dass ich bald 2,5 Gigabit aufbauen werde, aber es gibt Aufbauten. Aber es fährt viele Kameras, fährt meine VLANs, fährt alles. Es ist wirklich das Hub meines ganzen Netzwerkes.
Du siehst hier, dass es eine 10 Gigabit-Aufbauten-Linie zu meinem Switch gibt.
Das ist wirklich was, da könnten sich die großen Anbieter mal was überlegen. Warum liefern die nicht Racks mit LED-Leisten am Rand, dass du einfach, wenn du da drin was machen musst, das komplette Rack erleuchten kannst. Das wäre nicht cool, das würde schon was helfen.
Ein weiterer Aufbauten-Linie zum Port 24, das ist mein WAN, der aufbaut. Das ist wahrscheinlich ein unpopulares Opinion, weil es selten gemacht wird, oder vielleicht hast du noch nie ein Opinion geformt, aber es gefällt dir nicht.
Moment, was ist denn das für ein Ding? Hat UniFi mittlerweile auch eine USB oder was?
Power in the front finde ich jetzt auch nicht so verkehrt. Ich meine, normalerweise haben Racks an der Seite Panels für den Strom. Normalerweise hast du hier Panels, Steckdosen an der Seite. Aber ich habe in meinem Mini-Rack auch ganz normale Steckdosen, da ist die drin.
Warum haben die eine USB mit USB-C? Ah, dass du da drüber Raspberry Pi oder so anschließen könntest. Was ist das da unten? Wofür ist das da unten?
Ja, gut. Ein weird chap.
Ist das jetzt eine USB oder ist das einfach nur eine fancy Steckdosenleiste?
Das kann man mit einer stecknormalen Steckdosenleiste auch.
Okay, USB-Ding. Was ist der Sinn davon?
280 geht noch irgendwo klar.
Okay, das ist tatsächlich ganz sinnvoll, eine schaltbare Steckdosenleiste. Aber wie gesagt, ich könnte auch meine schaltbare Steckdosenleiste benutzen, die ich mit Tasmota geflasht habe, die mich 30 Euro kostet.
Was eine Steckdosenleiste mit Internet-Ausfällen zu tun hat, verstehe ich auch nicht. Ach so, weil du deinen Internetmodem resetten könntest.
Wirklich? Wirklich? Den Sinn verstehen tue ich davon jetzt nicht.
Okay, sie ist aber nice looking. Das muss ich ihm zugestehen. Wenn er denkt, es ist nice looking und er will Unify Style Rack haben, warum nicht?
Also ich könnte auch einfach meine 30 Euro Tasmota geflechte Steckdosenleiste nehmen. Die hat zwar nur 4 Stecker und 4xUSB, aber das reicht ja in der Regel an Geräten, die du wirklich remote ein- und ausschalten willst.
Na gut. An deine China Steckdosenleiste würde ich keinen Server anschließen. Warum nicht? Das ist eine Steckdosenleiste, die du ganz normal bei Amazon.de kaufen kannst und die für alles mögliche funktioniert. Warum sollte die für einen Server nicht auch funktionieren?
automatic text
Okay, 16. Okay, meine motion detection gibt mir nichtscreaming! Ich muss weiter loslegen, also passiert nicht. Was du hier üst um die 16 Startag- двerte privieren kannst,руfst kannst gegenwärtig diese auf und
auf ange perpendicular zu treiben, was wirklich outrochlich ist, und auf die shouldYourMetrics garection, von der Vielheit der Autofuhrar dying schenkt,
Sie waren ein wenig teuer zu Beginn.
Und dann dachte ich, hey, ich will ein paar smarte oder remotely genannte.
Dann sah ich, Unifi hatte sie.
Und ich dachte, wir werden auf einen anderen UPS laufen.
Wo ich diese auf und ab füllen kann.
Weil ich die Lichter nur über das Internet füllen kann.
Und dann dachte ich, ich fülle es, aber ich denke eigentlich, ich werde es wiederverpacken.
Mit meinen beiden interessanten Sachen.
Okay, also jetzt reden wir über Computer.
Es sieht ein bisschen aus wie alte HP Server.
Von den Farben her, aber es ist Super Micro.
Aber von der Farbgebung sieht das sehr HP Style aus.
Moin Flowey.
Glücklicherweise haben wir noch VGA, dann ist alles gut.
Die Dinger verbrauchen halt, die sind halt nicht dafür ausgelegt, großartig Strom zu sparen.
Aber ja, das ist tatsächlich so ein Ding.
Wenn man sich alte Hardware auf Ebay kauft, die verbraucht halt in der Regel massig Strom und ist auch relativ laut.
Ein paar neuere Generationen, die sind natürlich auch als Hardware fürs Rechenzentrum nicht darauf ausgelegt, super sparsam zu sein.
Aber allein schon, weil es eine neuere Architektur ist, brauchen die ein bisschen weniger.
Das ist gar kein VGA, stimmt, das ist ein serieller Port.
Das ist zweimal USB und serieller Port.
Gaka hat gar kein VGA.
Oh ja, hat Abschnitt hinten.
Ach stimmt, Proxmox hat er ja auch noch.
Plus Kubernetes Cluster, plus Rancher OS Cluster und alles.
Ja, von diesen neun VMs sind acht zur Selbstverwaltung.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, was er da laufen hat.
Kind of in use, gut, dass wir es haben.
Guck mal, da hat er das gleiche Gehäuse, wie ich früher hatte.
Guck mal, das ist das gleiche Gehäuse, was ich auch hatte.
Warte mal, ich muss euch ein altes Video zeigen, wo es die Kiste noch gibt.
Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max und was meint ihr, was die schnell...
Na, guck.
Wir haben das gleiche Case.
Okay, ich gebe zu, mein Rack ist natürlich nicht so advanced wie seins mit RGB-Beleuchtung und sowas.
Wobei das ja auch von 2007 ist.
Ein bisschen neuer, ein bisschen neuer.
Habe ich auch RGB-Beleuchtung.
Ja, also, immerhin.
Wisst ihr, was für mich ein weiterer Punkt ist, ist es nicht so sehr zu übertreiben mit Infrastruktur und Virtualisierung und Cluster.
Guck mal, ne, das Zeug und so daheim, ganz einfach.
Das Zeug braucht alles regelmäßige Warnungsarbeit.
Ja, du musst mal ein Versionsupdate machen, du musst auf deinen VMS-Patches einspielen, du musst gucken, dass du es an der richtigen Reihenfolge machst.
Du musst den ganzen Kram ab und zu vielleicht mal wegen Körnen updaten wie Bunt.
Du bist ja bestimmt den halben Tag dann quasi, wenn du Zeit hast damit beschäftigt, dann dich um deine Infrastruktur noch zu kümmern daheim.
Das ist für mich ein weiterer Punkt, warum ich es daheim nicht so übertreibe.
Ich habe früher es deutlich mehr übertrieben als jetzt.
Manch einer würde sagen, ein kleines Rack daheim stehen haben ist immer noch zu übertrieben.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, was ist bei mir drinnen?
Eigentlich auch nicht viel mehr als bei den meisten anderen, ja.
Ich meine, bei mir ist...
Bei mir ist drinnen...
Na, man sieht es ja im Endeffekt.
Aber mein 3D-Drucker steht oben drauf.
Oben habe ich meinen 10G-Switch.
Da unten drunter habe ich so einen mini Keystone-Patch-Panel, wo die Hälfte von nicht benutzt ist.
Dann habe ich eine Steckdosenleiste und dann habe ich einen Router und eine Fritzbox.
Und das Ding war früher der Server, den habe ich nicht mehr.
Da steht jetzt ein HP... Achso, und die USB ist auch raus.
Da steht jetzt ein HP-Micro-Server drinnen.
Also im Prinzip ist es auch nicht viel mehr als die meisten sonst zu haben.
Noch mehr Storage, ich denke, er hat einen Story-Nator da oben.
Das ist einfach nur da und an.
Ach Moment, das hier unten ist gar kein Server.
Das ist quasi nur so eine Disk-Extension oder wie?
Das kann man machen.
Gibt ihr extra so ein SAS-Kabel für sowas, so ein SAS-Extender?
Mein gesamtes Rack braucht weniger.
Hast du eigentlich ein Elektroauto?
Ja, ich habe es seit August oder so, glaube ich.
Ende August, ihr wisst besser, wann ich es gekauft habe, habe ich ein Elektroauto.
Ein Fiat 500e.
Und vor drei Wochen habe ich ihn kaputt gemacht.
Aber er geht wieder.
Also ich habe den Reifen kaputt gemacht.
Ist das eine USB?
Das ist eine USB.
Dachte das in der Mitte, war schon seine USB.
Hatte er nicht mal in einem alten Video sogar so eine komische Konsole in seinem Rack?
Wo ich dachte, warum?
Ja, ich habe ein Ladegerät im Hof. Im Hof ist das.
Da hatten wir es vorhin von. Ich habe dieses Ladegerät.
Go e-Charger Home Fix.
Und das Ding habe ich mir einbauen lassen, weil es offene AP-Dokumentation hat.
Also man kann es in seine Heimautomatisierung einbinden.
Weil der Hersteller ist nicht, ja, closed alles, sodass man nicht dran kommt gemacht hat.
Sondern eben über MQTT, ATTP oder irgendwelche Modbus-Geschichten.
Aber man will nicht dazwischen dazwischen in der Dunkelheit sein.
Aber ich weiß, dass es da ist und ich habe alle Power-Kabel, die ich brauche, raus gemacht.
Also habe ich es nach hinten gemacht.
Das ist nicht für eine Kooperative, aber fantastisch für eine Heimautomatisierung.
Weil ich etwas Spass konservieren wollte.
Also jetzt, dass wir das sehen, schauen wir uns an die Rückseite.
Ihr könnt mein Kabel-Management schauen und ich zeige euch, wie alles wirkt.
Ich will seine Services sehen oder zeige dir das in diesem Video gar nicht mehr.
Den Service-Overview. Ach, der Service-Overview kommt erst noch.
Weil wie gesagt, ich will wissen, ob er mittlerweile sinnvolle Sachen drauf betreibt.
Ja gut, das muss man sich jetzt nicht angucken.
Das ist alles vollkommen in Ordnung.
Das ist alles in Ordnung.
Kann man alles machen.
Also ich habe schon deutlich Schlimmeres gesehen.
Zum Beispiel meins.
Aber ich habe auch schon im wirklich Profi-Umfeld deutlich Schlimmeres gesehen.
Das ist alles vollkommen in Ordnung.
Aber ich habe auch schon deutlich Schlimmeres gesehen.
Kannst du mal ein Video zu KeyPass machen?
Was willst du da wissen? Ich meine, du installierst das Programm und benutzt es.
Das ist relativ selbsterklärend.
Was willst du da wissen?
Okay, was auch immer.
Wenn du mich mit dem Smartphone aufweichst und einfach weißer ist, kann ich so einfach weiße Sachen sehen.
Wenn du mich mit dem Smartphone aufweichst und einfach weiße Sachen sehen.
Wenn du mir mit dem Smartphone aufweichst und einfach weiße Sachen sehen.
Pass gesyncht über einen eigenen Syncing Service, da müssen die Geräte halt einmal
im WLAN sein und du synchst, das muss ja gar nicht übers Internet gehen.
Das ist okay, ich würde aber, also ich persönlich gehe noch nicht mal so weit und lege meinen
Key Pass nach Google Drive.
Ich würde noch nicht mal meinen Key Pass in die Cloud schieben, solange es die eigene
Infrastruktur ist, okay, ich würde aber auch nicht deswegen mir einen VPN einrichten,
dass ich von außen drauf zugreifen kann, wenn ich synken will, kann ich ja immer noch
das machen, wenn ich bei mir im WLAN hänge, dass es dann Tablet, Desktop und Smartphone
mit der neuesten Version synkt, es reicht ja, wenn das intern passiert, das muss ja
nicht übers Internet zwangsläufig sein.
Man muss sich halt wirklich fragen, was braucht man denn da eigentlich wirklich und was bildet
man sich ein zu brauchen?
Ich glaube, viele bilden sich ein mehr zu brauchen, als sie wirklich täglich eigentlich
benutzen von.
Sollte ich zu Apple wechseln, würdest du eine Passwortverwaltung, nö, ich würde
gar keine im Prinzip die Passwortverwaltung antrauen, von denen ich nicht weiß, was
passiert.
Du hast manchmal keine richtige Wahl, also wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel sagst, nehm mal
meine Scalable App, die sich alle 30 Tage oder so oder alle 3 Monate mal auslockt oder
alle 6 Wochen, ja, da brauche ich das Passwort halt, entweder gehe ich dann jedes Mal zum
Rechner und tipps ein oder ich speichere es irgendwo im Mobil und ich speichere es aktuell
tatsächlich im lokalen iPhone Keystore, was da halt dabei ist.
Vertrauen tue ich denen nicht, aber es ist für mich der beste Kompromiss.
Aber ich mache es halt auch nicht für alle Passwörter.
So, ich glaube, in dem Video gibt es nichts spannendes mehr zu sehen, ja, also ich bin
ja mal gespannt, was er dann uns nächste Woche erzählen wird, was er denn da drauf
wirklich benutzt, weil ich sehe da bisher nicht so viel spannendes.
Ich bin ja mal gespannt, ob sich das verbessert hat, das letzte Mal hat er wie gesagt 80%
gehabt, um seine Infrastruktur selbst zu verwalten.
Du kannst dir nicht sicher sein, ich hab zumindest keinen Cloud Sync drauf, ob das
wirklich rein lokal bleibt, man weiß es halt nicht, das ist das, du kannst im Endeffekt
halt nicht richtig kontrollieren, deswegen verlassen die wichtigsten Passwörter auch
meine Infrastruktur nie.
Ich glaube nicht, 100% nicht sicher, kannst du dir da aber nie sein, doch kann ich, ich
habe iCloud ausgeschaltet und nicht verbunden, aber trotzdem, du weißt nicht, ob da Kram
nicht irgendwie an Apple ab ist, kannst du nicht wissen, deswegen finde ich es auch blöd,
alle Passwörter immer zu jeder Zeit überall hinzusücken.
Richtig, genau, sowas kann man, das ist eine gute Idee, ja, ich meine, in irgendeinem Tod
musst du sterben, irgendwo musst du ja die Passwörter mal eintippen und manchmal willst
du halt auch das nicht jedes Mal machen, aber ich würde halt nicht so weit gehen und sagen,
pauschal alles in einen Cloud Password Manager zusammenschmeißen und immer und überall
irgendwo hinzusücken, weil du brauchst das in der Regel nicht und wenn dann schon gar
nicht in den Cloud Password Manager, wenn schon dann über dein eigenes Keypass-File oder
irgendwas, wo ich halt selbst, wo ich zumindest halbwegs nachvollziehen kann, was passiert.
Ok was können wir sonst noch angucken, zeig mal her, Epic Paying, ja das habe ich gelesen,
dass Epic Strafe bezahlen muss.
Kommt drauf an, wenn man diagonal skaliert, so wie wir, ist das alles kein Problem, aber
die Noobs skalieren ja noch vertikal oder horizontal, das ist ja outdated, richtig coole
Leute skalieren diagonal, über 20.000 Brezeln pro, wir gucken uns jetzt an, was der Bäckermeister
verdient.
Warum hast du denn Angst, dass Keypass in Dropbox liegt, glaubst du das File geöffnet
werden kann ohne das?
Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Frage, also prinzipiell mal unabhängig davon, ob es knackbar
ist oder nicht, prinzipiell ist glaube ich eine Sache ganz klar, Daten, die du nicht
rausgegeben hast, können prinzipbedingt nicht irgendwo missbraucht werden, weil die sind
da nicht da, also was nicht da ist, kann ich kaputt gehen im Endeffekt, also schau mal
das erste, so der erste große Grund, warum ich nicht prinzipiell alles irgendwie sinken
würde, irgendwo hinlegen, das sagst du bei jedem Cloud Password Manager, deswegen bin
ich auch Cloud Password Manager kacke, so das ist schon mal das erste, so das zweite ist,
wenn man jetzt sagt, ok ich muss aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen den Kram sinken will
ich, dann ist der Ansatz von Keypass in Dropbox gar nicht so verkehrt, aber eine Sache, die
man da auch nicht vergessen darf und die immer passieren kann ist, sobald, also du musst
davon ausgehen, sobald die Daten einmal in der Cloud waren oder sobald die Daten einmal
außerhalb deines hoheitsbereichs waren, also deiner Infrastruktur waren, musst du davon
ausgehen, dass die Daten prinzipiell irgendwo gespeichert sind, ja selbst wenn du die von
Dropbox löscht, ob die jemals aus dem Internet verschwinden bzw. von irgendwelchen Archiven
verschwinden, weiß man nicht, also mit dem Hochladen in irgendeine Cloud musst du davon
ausgehen, dass dieser Datensatz für immer bis zum Ende aller Tage der Menschheit irgendwo
verfügbar sein wird, was auch bedeutet, dass wenn vielleicht der Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus,
der verwendet wurde um die Passwörter zu verschlüsseln, in 10 Jahren Probleme hat, dass man dann einfach
vielleicht erst in 10 Jahren in dein Passwortsafe reingucken kann und vielleicht stehen da wirklich
private Dinger drinnen, ich meine in diesen Saves kannst du ja Dokumente speichern, theoretische
Notizen und alles und halt auch Seiten und Passwörter, ist halt die Frage, wie relevant
die Daten in 10 Jahren noch sind, kann ich persönlich nicht einschätzen, also deswegen
würde ich auch nicht sagen, ja ich finde es okay, dass vielleicht in 10 Jahren die Sachen
einer lesen kann, es ist recht unwahrscheinlich, dass IAS 256 in 10 Jahren useless ist, aber
ganz ehrlich, ich kann nicht abschätzen, was in 10 Jahren ist, ich weiß auch nicht, ob
nicht irgendwie rauskommt, dass der Anbieter bzw. die Software, die ich verwendet habe,
nicht vielleicht Sicherheitslücken hat, wo man in 3 Jahren feststellt, ach Mist, KeyPass
oder LastPass oder was es nicht alles gibt, hatte irgendwelche Probleme in ihrer Software,
vielleicht kommt das ja in 3 Jahren raus, die hatten Probleme in ihrer Software und alle
Passwortdatenbanken, die mit der Software unter Version XY angelegt wurden, sind unsicher,
kann doch sein, also du musst davon ausgehen, dass die Sachen einmal im Internet gewesen
sind, immer im Internet sind und man die dir vielleicht in 5-10 Jahren easy entschlüsseln
kann und dann ist halt die Frage, wie relevant ist das noch, was da drin steht, will ich
das und ich sage, will ich nicht.
Gibt es eigentlich ein Tool, das smart genug ist, Passworts vollautomatisch alle X Wochen
zu recyceln?
Keine Ahnung, der müsste ja sich quasi einloggen können und bei allen Diensten wissen, wie
ein Passwort der X wechselt, ich glaube nicht, dass das funktioniert, es gibt sicherlich
Passwortmanager und Passworttools, die dich darauf hinweisen, das Passwort ist älter
als, aber so automatisch wechseln, glaube ich nicht, ja TrueCrypt ist ein schönes Beispiel
für.
Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung schützt sich auch nicht zwangsläufig davor, weil eines
der Hauptanliegen der Leute, warum die solche Passwortmanager verwenden ist ja Bequemlichkeit
und Leute, die das rein aus Bequemlichkeitsgründen verwenden, die machen ihre OTP-Generierung
eventuell auch gleich mit über die Passwortmanager-App, also OTP ist ja das, was du bei Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung
eingeben musst und meistens über irgendeine Authentificator-App und wenn du jetzt Authentificator-App
und Passwortmanager in einem hast, naja, dann ist das auch weg, weil diese Authentificator-Apps,
die können ja auch nicht zaubern, die haben ein gemeinsames Secret mit dem Server anhand
der Uhrzeit und des jeweiligen vorher ausgehandelten Generierungsverfahrens generieren die dir
einen Schlüssel passend für die nächsten 45 Sekunden und wenn du dieses gemeinsames
Secret, was du in der Server hast, im Passwort Vault, im Passwortmanager irgendwo gespeichert
hast, dann hast du quasi Passwort und den zweiten Faktor zusammen direkt zugreifbar,
bringt dir auch nichts.
Dann hast du so Sachen wie SMS oder Anrufe, Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung, als du angerufen
wirst und das hat man letztens gerade bei dem Überhack gesehen, der Typ ist an einen Account
und an Passwort, also der Angreifer ist dort an einen Account und ein Passwort gekommen
und was hat er gemacht, er hat einfach nachts um 3.45 Uhr die Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung
gestartet und der Typ war so blöd, es auf dem Handy zu bestätigen, da wirst du angerufen
und sagt, hallo, hier ist Microsoft Authenticator, drücken sie jetzt die Raute-Taste, wenn sie
sich einloggen wollen, dann ist er nachts um 3.40 Uhr ans Handy gegangen, hat den altbekannten
Anruf bekommen, hat halt Raute gedrückt und zack, ist eingeloggt, eben ist es dann später
glaube ich gedämmert, aber zu spät, also auch Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung schützt
dich so prinzipiell nicht komplett, es ist natürlich immer noch besser, Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung
zu haben, aber es ist halt immer so, nur weil eine Sache jetzt unsicher ist, heißt es nicht,
dass man mit allem anderen leichtsinnig sein soll, wie dumm muss man auch sein, ich weiß
nicht wie blöd du wärst, wenn nachts um 3.45 Uhr dein Handy klingelt, du bist total verschlafen
und du hörst einen Anruf, den du schon 8.000 Mal gehört hast und immer das gleiche gemacht
hast, nämlich Raute drücken, also es hat funktioniert, easy, und ob die Uber Leute jetzt so doof
sind, weiß ich nicht, also ich behaupte mal, das könnte prinzipiell gut gemacht jedem
passieren oder den meisten passieren, du kannst das natürlich noch beliebig aufbohren,
du kannst dann 3-Faktor-Authentifizierung oder wie Julien Bam was hatte der 5-Faktor-Authentifizierung
machen, bringt dir auch alles nichts, wenn irgendwie einer deine Session-Cookies klaut
aus dem Browser, aber gut, andere Probleme, du kannst auch 3-Faktor-Authentifizierung
machen, da hast du noch irgendeinen Key mit Token-Generierung, kannst du das beliebig
aufbohren, aber das werden dann die Leute, die das rein aus Bequemlichkeitsgründen alles
in Passwort-Manager-Speichern auch nicht machen.
Also wie gesagt, ich würde mich da nicht täuschen und ich würde das auch nicht so
sehr auf die leichte Schulter nehmen und ich habe es in meinem Video gestern gesehen, dass
viele Leute sich das immer noch schönreden mit Cloud-Passwort-Managern und ach da passiert
doch nichts oder ach mein Anbieter, mein Anbieter ist doch sicherlich sicher oder ach ich verwende
einen der großen Anbieter, da kann doch eigentlich gar nichts passieren oder ich habe da noch
2-Faktor-Authentifizierung oder die Active-Accounts, die ich drin habe, sind eh nicht so schlimm.
Leute, da würde ich mich nicht drauf verlassen.
Cloud-Passwort-Manager, die nicht in eurer Hoheit liegen, noch schlimmer welche, wo ihr
nicht wisst, welche Software dort läuft bzw. was die überhaupt machen und euch rein auf
die Aussagen der Passwort-Manager-Anbieter verlassen müsst, sind eine unglaublich doofe
Idee.
Die haben die, naja, was haben die denn gemacht, entweder haben die einfach den PC ferngesteuert,
also wenn du irgendein Remote, irgendein Trojaner-Mailware-Zeug auf dem Rechner hast, entweder steuerst du
direkt den Rechner fern und machst es da drüber oder du klaust dir eben alle Cookies und alle
Sessions und machst es dann von dir aus.
Einfacher ist es, zumindest auch weniger feststellbar natürlich, wenn du das von dem Rechner aus
machst, wenn du da irgendwelche Remote-Zugriffsmöglichkeiten hast, ja, ist natürlich besser, weil
dann ändert sich auch die IP und sonst nix.
Irgendjemand hat irgendwas gerade gefragt, wo ich noch was zu sagen wollte, ich weiß
gar nicht.
Also ja, das mit Dropbox habe ich ja schon beantwortet.
Hatten wir auch schon.
Ja, ist schön, dass es die Leute interessiert.
Es ist ja gut, wenn das auch irgendwie auf fruchtbaren Boden fällt, ja.
Eventuell Bitworn auf Meta-Server, ob die Zugriff haben, ja gut, das ist auch noch so
eine Zwischenlösung, die man machen kann, wenn man das nicht in seinen eigenen vier
Wänden betreiben will, man könnte sich beispielsweise auch eine NVM irgendwo mieten und das da drauf
machen, wobei es da halt auch wieder so ein Ding ist, also wie weit traue ich dem Anbieter
und was ist es für eine Software, also sprich, wenn das irgendein Key Vault ist, der die
Sachen im RAM hat, entschlüsselt, also sprich, dass nicht nur verschlüsselte Sachen ausgetauscht
werden und dann klein-seitig das entschlüsselt wird, also wenn der Server jemals das Passwort
im Klartext sieht, dann würde ich das nicht machen, weil es steht halt nicht bei dir daheim,
ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass Hetzer da was macht, aber wenn die Polizei vor der Tür
steht und sagt, hey, wir müssen da mal ran, wer weiß, was du für Dinger getrieben hast,
vielleicht hast du auch keine Dinger getrieben und bist einfach zufällig irgendwie passt
ins Muster, aber wenn dann die Polizei vor der Tür steht und sagt, hey, wir müssen da
mal kurz ran, die werden da auf jeden Fall kooperieren müssen sie ja und wenn die Sachen
unverschlüsselt im RAM liegen, ist halt immer eine Frage, wie realistisch da ist das Ganze,
kann man nicht sagen, deswegen, es ist durchaus eine denkbare Sache, dass man so einen SYNC,
ich würde vielleicht nicht den Passwortsafe direkt auf den Server legen, aber vielleicht
den SYNC über einen Hetzer Server laufen lassen, das ist zum Beispiel, was ich mir
durchaus vorstellen kann, sprich, dass ich einen Keypass habe, aber ich lasse irgendwie
den FilesYNC laufen über einen externen Server, so dass ich es eben über mein Handy
auf mein Handy SYNCen kann und auf Tablets, wenn ich unterwegs bin und hin und zurück,
das könnte man zum Beispiel machen.
Ja, aber verschlüsselte Disk bringt ja auch nur zum Teil was, ja, also solange der Server
an ist, ist es ja entsperrt das System, musst du ja, also solange es eingeschaltet ist,
natürlich kann man da verschiedene Vorkehrungen noch treffen, aber das ist erstmal ganz okay,
ja.
Das ist schon mal besser als irgendeinen Clouddienst zu verwenden.
Ah ja, und wenn ich irgendwelche Sachen in der Cloud speichern würde, also auf irgendeinem
eigenen, für irgendeine eigene VM, dann muss das Ding natürlich voll verschlüsselt sein,
ansonsten ist er eh bescheuert.
Das muss komplett, das muss beim booten mindestens mal ein Passport eingegeben werden, besser
irgendein Zertifikat noch, aber Passport ist das Mindeste, also muss beim booten, muss
das Ding entsperrt werden, sonst hat es ja keinen Sinn.
Gibt es ja mittlerweile auch Möglichkeiten, also du kannst ja, wenn das ordentlich eingerichtet
ist, kannst du ja einen SSH Server im Bootprozess starten und dann gibst du ein Passport über
SSH ein und erst dann wird die Hauptpartition entschlüsselt und das Betriebssystem startet.
Das haben wir im Stream auch schon gemacht vor längerer Zeit, sowohl lokal als auch
bei Hetzner.
Bei Hetzner, weiß ich noch, war es ein bisschen größerer Akt, das booten von einem eigenen
Installer damals, war noch ein bisschen Trick 17, genau, Chopper ist das, ja, ja, genau,
das war damals ein bisschen Trick 17, das haben wir irgendwie bei Netboot damals gelöst.
Ich glaube mittlerweile kannst du bei Hetzner relativ einfach eigene Isos auch booten und
dann machst du halt den Installer selbst und verschlüsselst die Festplatte voll und dann
musst du nur noch einrichten, dass du über SSH entschlüsseln kannst.
Kann man alles machen, ist sinnvoll, wenn man es denn braucht.
Ich brauche es nicht, also ich habe keinen Bedarf für permanenten Sync, außer und innerhalb
von meinem Netzwerk, die paar Dienste, die ich auf dem Handy brauche, habe ich mir eingeloggt
bzw. habe es lokal dort gespeichert, gut ist, wenn man das braucht, dann ist es sicherlich
sinnvoll, das über so einen Weg zu machen, als über einen Cloud Password Manager.
Es ist genau das gleiche, alle die jetzt sagen, ach mein Cloud Anbieter ist sicher, die waren
halt zufällig bei einem anderen, aber die Lastpass Kunden haben sich das gleiche gedacht.
Guck mal, wenn man sich die Comments unter meinem letzten Video anguckt, da sind ganz
viele eben, die sich schönreden, nach dem Motto, ja mein Password Manager Anbieter ist
sicherlich sicher oder wenn man das richtig benutzt, es ist eh kein Problem und sowas.
Naja, selbst schuld, was anderes wie gesagt, ich halte Cloud Password Manager an für eine
echt blöde Idee.
Aber nicht, wenn du deine Passwörter in der Cloud speicherst, bei einem Anbieter, wo du
nicht weißt, was du machst, natürlich kriegst du auch dein eigenes Netzwerk nicht 100%
sicher, aber nur weil dein eigenes Netzwerk und deine Sachen nicht 100% sicher kriegst,
ist es nicht, dass du quasi jetzt, wenn du über die Straße läufst, guckst du trotzdem
nach links und rechts, obwohl es nicht 100% sicher ist, dass du nicht stirbst beim drüber
laufen.
Also, obwohl du geguckt hast, aber es ist trotzdem eine blöde Idee zu sagen, ja, da kann ich
es auch einfach bei einem Cloud Anbieter speichern.
Password Manager sind sinnvoll, aber keine Cloud Password Manager, keine Cloud Password
Manager.
Das ist auch eine gute Idee, kann man auch machen.
Also wenn die zu unfähig sind, lokale Password Manager zu bedienen und damit nicht klarkommen,
dann sollen die sich einfach einen Zettel in den Schrank legen.
Zettel in den Schrank hat nämlich auch noch einen weiteren großen Vorteil, wenn du dir
irgendwelche Viren auf deinem Rechner eingefangen hast, der guckt nicht in deinen Schrank, der
guckt aber schon auf dein USB-Stick und auf deine Festplatte.
Also bevor sie sich eine Password TXT auf den Desktop legen, sollen sie sich einen Zettel
in den Schrank legen, wenn sie es nicht so oft brauchen, wenn sie es nicht hinbekommen.
Michael, 50 Billionen, Dankeschön für den Sub, 29 Monate, da ist er wieder.
Wenn ihr es nicht oft braucht, könnt ihr den Key Pass auf den Winners Laufwerk Winnershare
legen.
Das ist das einfachste und simpelste, was man machen kann oder sowas hier, wobei es
nicht Bitworn ist, sondern, das wurde ja jetzt umbenannt, das Alternativprojekt, kannst du
das nehmen, das ist auch ganz gut, wenn es was modernes mit Webinterface und so sein
soll.
Und es ist Written in Rust, Written in Rust ist ja bekanntlichermaßen immer besser als
alles andere.
EDV Forensik ist am Start, das passt ja mal wieder wie die Faust aufs Auge zu dem Thema,
dass EDV Forensik am Start ist, für den Sub EDV Forensik, du kommst wie gerufen hier,
was sagst du zum Thema EDV Forensik, wie findest du Cloudbasierte Passwort Manager, bei dem
Name will ich das jetzt wissen, aber danke für den Sub, ja ich weiß, kann man sich überlegen
was man da verwendet, aber solange es nicht irgendwas Cloudbasiert ist, wo du keine Ahnung
hast, was die machen, ist es schon mal besser, weiß ich nicht, hab ich nicht verwendet.
So, also wir wollen uns ja angucken, was der Bäckermeister verdient, wahrscheinlich viel
zu wenig.
Denkt ihr mal dran, es ist auch fast egal, welchen der Passwort Manager ihr verwendet,
solange ihr ein Kackmaster Passwort verwendet.
Find ich nicht besonders gut, ok, das hab ich mir gedacht, das sind wir einer Meinung,
also ihr braucht ein ordentliches Master Passwort, da führt nichts dran vorbei, weil nur weil
ihr jetzt was anderes verwendet, wird es nicht dadurch sicherer, und ein zweiter Faktor
schadet auch nicht.
1, 2, 3, 4, ich dachte 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 ist best practice als Passwort, ja das ist auch
nice, ja, exellent, gut, was hältst du von den neuen V-Pass Keeps, sagt mir gar nichts,
keine Ahnung, stimmt, für Forensik müsstest du es eigentlich gut finden, musst dich nicht
so anstrengen, hast alles auf einer Stelle, aber so ein Keep Pass mit Keyfile und einem
Vault of Dropbox als Back, das kann man machen, wie gesagt, wenn man den Sync haben will,
kann man das machen, aber es muss immer klar sein, sobald man das irgendwie wo hoch lädt,
ist es für immer im Internet, und wer weiß, wie es in 5-10 Jahren aussieht, ob man das
nicht einfach entschlüsseln kann, ja, das ist schon mal eine gute Sache, so, jetzt gucken
wir uns an, was ein Bäckermeister verdient, das wollte ich dir immer wissen, weil 20.000
Brezeln, ne, nicht am Tag, in der Woche, also, BPW sozusagen, 20.000 BPW, ich meine eigentlich
ist diese Einheit, Brezeln pro Woche, auch nicht viel schlimmer als, wie heißt das,
B-T-U, B-P-U, B-P-U, ne, B-T-U, B-T-U pro Stunde, genau, B-T-U, B-P-U, B-P-U, B-P-U,
also, das ist die größte Bullshit-Einheit, die heutzutage noch verwendet wird, guckt
euch das mal an, British Thermal Unit ist eine Einheit der Energie, Definition, also,
eine B-T-U ist definiert als die Wärmeenergie, die benötigt wird, ein britisches Pfund Wasser
um ein Grad Fahrenheit zu erwerben, also, Merkel-Kona-Style oder UK-Style geht ja eigentlich
kaum noch, das ist wirklich die schlimmste Einheit überhaupt, die noch irgendwie im Umlauf
ist, was das angeht, also, mal davon abgesehen, was auch schlimm ist, ist generell die Gewichtseinheiten,
wenn du beispielsweise dir anguckst, aha, was wiegt denn das, oder hast du dann bei
den Amis acht Ounces, was, wie viel wiegt die jetzt, irgendeine Maus acht Ounces und
sowas, hä, na gut, also was macht der Bäckermeister jetzt, also wie gesagt, ich bevorzuge Brezeln
pro Woche als Einheit versus B-T-U, ups, Moment, das ist das falsche Video, wo ist der Bäckermeister,
da ist der Bäckermeister, oh nee, Tossmusik, Arbeiten ohne Geld zu verdienen ist eine schlechte
Idee, ja, das stimmt, ist das Tossmusik, das ist bestimmt Tossmusik, Toss, Toss, Toss,
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Monka Toss, Monka Toss, Monka Toss, Alter, wie das rausgekickt
wird, habt ihr es gesehen, richtig raus, wie sagt man heute, rausgegetet, guckt euch das
mal an, bäm, weg ist das Brötchen was, Servus, ich bin der Sebastian, bin 30 Jahre alt und
bin von Beruf Bäckermeister im elterlichen Betrieb, oah, 4.30 Uhr, wobei ich sage 4.30
Uhr, früher bin ich ganz selbstverständlich 5.45 Uhr aufgestanden nach Frankfurt gefahren,
glücklicherweise hat sich der Mist erledigt, heute ist es kalt, wir haben hier unsere Vorbestellungen
und dann sehe ich, dass wir heute Partybrötchen 700 Stück machen müssen, das ist relativ viel
Arbeit, weil wir die halt mit der Hand flechten, ich bin dafür verantwortlich, dass, zum 4.30
geht's los, da steht ja nicht mal 4.30 Uhr auf, wenn was bestellt wird von den Kunden
auch dann wirklich bei den Kunden ankommt, das tue ich jetzt mal, den hinter, jetzt geht's
in die Backstube, Morgen, Morgen, Morgen, schau mal, das ist jetzt der Zettel für die
ganze Woche, das ist jetzt morgen 700, definitiv Weihnachten und Ostern, Weihnachten einfach,
weil man da schon Wochen vorher eigentlich nur im Stress war und dann noch der Heiligabend
der Grünen der Abschluss ist, in der Konditorei, da ist auch mein Vater, ja und dann geht's
los, also ich weiß am Anfang der Saison noch nicht so auswendig das Rezept, da muss ich
immer nachschauen, später weiß ich es dann immer, ein bisschen müde Eindruck macht er
auch, auswendig wieder, das ist jetzt Marzipan, jeder der weiß, was Marzipan kostet, Alter
du hast ein fettes Stück Marzipan, kostet kann ich vorstellen, was so ein riesen Block
kostet, das sind 12 Kilo, also 100 Euro, im letzten Winter hat es halt nur 50 Euro gekostet
und das macht es halt dann für uns, einfach weniger nehmen und für den gleichen Preis
verkaufen, schwierig, so, und jetzt Teigruhe, die größte Herausforderung ist eigentlich
die, dass ich mit einem Rohstoff zu tun habe, der jeden Tag anders sein kann, da schaue
ich jetzt meistens, dass halt alles passt, ich messe jetzt nicht bei jedem Teig die Temperatur,
irgendwie hört er sich ein bisschen mitgenommen an oder?
Grad bei Brezen oder so da hin und wieder mal zu messen ist nicht verkehrt, bei zu kalten
Teigen, da kriege ich keine schöne splitterige Kruste hin, bei dem Brezenteig wäre es ganz
gut, wenn er so zwischen 20 und 21 Grad hat, oh zu kalt, zu kalter Brezelteig, jetzt,
dann hat man die Möglichkeit, ihn einfach länger zu kneten, durch die Knetung habe
ich ja eine Reibung und die Reibung ist Energie, die dann wieder zu Wärme führt, hey 21 Grad,
ein Blödsinn probieren, schaut dazu, sicher ist es in der Wahrheit nach, ich nenne es
Qualitätskontrolle, ich lasse mir mal den Hauptteig laufen, das sind die eingeweichten
Rosinen, es gibt immer zwei Punkte, wo man ganz genau aufpassen muss, das ist die Teigbereitung,
also das Untermischen der Früchte, da passiert ganz schnell mal ein Fehler und dann ausbacken.
Da muss man halt aufpassen, dass er eben nicht schwindlig wird, wenn man reinschaut.
Oh, das ist Toss, das ist ganz in Roses, das müssen wir ausmachen, man, Toss, Toss, Toss,
Toss.
Was ich dann auch immer beim ersten Kaffee mache, ich schaue, was ist jetzt gestern gegangen.
Erstmal auf Reddit gucken.
Wenn der Umsatz schon schlecht ist, beim gleichbleibenden Kosten, dann wird es halt schwierig.
Deswegen muss man schon schauen, dass die Umsätze passen.
Das ist so eine Aufgabe, die gehört alltäglich dazu, weil wenn ich arbeite ohne Geld zu verdienen,
dann sollte ich es irgendwann halt mal lassen.
Da ist was dran, ja.
Vor allem, wenn da hängt ja noch mehr hinten dran.
Das ist ja nicht nur bei ihm jetzt, sondern der ganze Laden hängt ja da mit dran.
Mr. Moogam, danke schön.
Die passen momentan schon, wir würden da auf relativ hohem Niveau klagen.
Die Brezenmaschine ist kaputt.
Erstmal Support-Call aufmachen.
Hey, wie wäre es, wenn ihr mal den Sensor kontrolliert?
Na, da wird einfach weitergemacht, oh Wunder, oh Wunder.
Das ist halt wichtig, dass das schöne läuft.
Jetzt gibt es erstmal Anschiss.
Die drei Maschinen da, 250, 150, 150.
Das heißt, da hinten mit den drei Maschinen, wo wir vorher waren,
sind wir ganz schnell mal bei 550.000 Euro.
Backofen, jeder 100.000 Euro.
Na gut, so Maschinen sind halt teuer.
Kühlanlagen, 50.000 Euro, von denen Backofen 30.000 Euro mal drei.
Und dann wahrscheinlich am 40 Euro Wartungsvertrag gespart.
90.000 Euro, der da hat auch 90.000 Euro gekostet.
Es kommt eine Summe zusammen.
Man sieht ja jetzt, es ist viel ruhiger alles.
So, Rätsel.
Ich muss jetzt hier die Rampe hoch.
Das ist das erste dieser Videos,
wo die Hälfte der Laufzeit einfach nur arbeitet.
Am wenigsten gearbeitet hat, glaube ich, diese Projektmanager-Beraterin.
Die hat zwei Mal am Tag in Nexl was eingetragen und den Rest ist nix passiert.
Oh nein, Toss, immer mehr Toss, Toss Musik.
Hört doch auf.
Mensch, Sensor kontrolliert.
Toss, immer mehr Toss, Toss Musik, hört doch auf.
Mensch, ZDF, BR.
Hört auf mit eurer Toss-Musik, was soll ich da machen?
Ich muss jetzt drüberschwätzen, weil Toss, Toss...
Das ist jetzt gefährlich.
Wir sind jetzt 40 fit.
Wenn man jetzt sagt, ein paar Stunden für 28 Euro,
nehmen wir einfach mal 25 Euro, dann sind es 1000 Euro wahnwert.
Da könnte jetzt schon was schiefgehen, gerade bei Stollen,
wegen der Kerntemperatur.
Da misst man dann auch nach und schaut, passt das, passt das nicht.
Erst mal prayen, ne Runde.
Jetzt backen Sie.
Jetzt kann ich nix mehr machen.
Jetzt hilft nur noch beten.
Jetzt kann ich nix mehr eingreifen.
Genau, das ist die Oma.
Zeig her, oder?
So viel Zeit habe ich nicht.
Qualitätskontrolle.
Bei uns muss kein Mitarbeiter Hunger leiden.
Wenn man Hunger hat, dann darf man was essen.
Ich finde, das gehört auch dazu, wenn ich im Lebensmittelhandwerk arbeite.
Vor allem, wenn ich den Kram selbst gemacht habe.
Dann essen darf, wenn ich Hunger habe
und nicht jeden Strich machen muss oder irgendwas.
Wie viel sollte er jetzt haben?
93, 94.
93, 93, 94, genau das, was er haben soll.
Jetzt wissen wir die Kerntemperatur.
Jetzt kann man noch schauen, wie ist die Backfarbe.
Ich glaube, die ist auch ganz gut gelungen.
Jetzt kommt wahrscheinlich massig Zucker drüber gleich.
Jetzt mache ich dann die Stollen fertig.
Also buttern und zuckern.
Tossmusik wieder.
Ach, scheiß drauf.
Ich singe jetzt nicht mit,
sondern dass Toss nicht Toss ist.
Schön viel Zucker, so muss das sein.
Man hat jetzt den ganzen Beitrag über einfach mal gearbeitet.
He sings a love song as we go along, walking in a winter wonderland.
Erst mal das Ding in Zucker tauchen.
Walking in a winter wonderland.
So, erst mal ganz den Zucker wieder weg.
Ich habe ein absolutes Gehalt von 4500 Euro Brutto und 3000 Euro Netto.
Also da sieht man durch die Nachtzuschläge,
ist tatsächlich vom Brutto mehr Netto übrig.
Und ich komme eigentlich ganz gut damit klar.
Jemand, der angestellt ist, der geht am Ende des Arbeitstages nach Hause
und weiß genau, wenn irgendwas ist, dann gibt es noch einen Chef.
Das ist halt schon ein Unterschied.
Und die Verantwortung muss auch in gewisser Weise honoriert werden.
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Die sind für morgen.
Wir sind alle riesen Löwen-Fans. Ich bin schon seit Geburt.
Was?
Und wenn dann...
Löwen-Fans? Ist das irgendein Fußballverein oder?
60 anfragt und sagt, hey, wie schaut es aus? Könnten wir Ware für die Profimannschaft haben?
Dann überlegt man nicht allzu lange.
Sicher überlegt man, aber nicht allzu lang.
Dann fangen wir jetzt einfach mal an.
Alter, heute ist ja Toss-Musik as fuck hier.
Es ist ja alles...
Na ja, was willst du machen?
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Es ist aber gut.
Da sind die Brezel. Die Brezen.
So, jetzt hoffe ich, dass ich nichts verliere.
Jetzt geht's ans Trainingsgelände von 1860.
Da liefern wir jetzt erst mal die frisch gebackenen Sachen hin.
Und dann fahren wir zurück, ziehen uns um und gehen selber dahin.
Als Gast.
Servus.
Ja, meistens sind es die Autos, die...
Hast du da nie gedruckt?
Warum?
Weil ich...
Weil er wahrscheinlich auch öfter seine Reifen kaputt fährt, so wie ich, und das ist teuer.
Meist ein relativ schönes Auto fahren möchte.
Okay, ich glaube, meinen Fiat fände er nicht schön.
Die Reifen kaputt kriege ich trotzdem hin.
Toss, Toss, Toss.
Der glücklichste Moment ist, wenn man ein Produkt rauszieht, womit man andere Leute begeistern kann.
Wenn die sagen, boah, ist das geil.
Sowas habe ich schon lange nicht mehr gekriegt.
Das sind die Momente, wo man sagt, ja, jetzt, das macht mich happy.
Jawohl. Viel Spaß.
Danke.
Alter, diesmal jetzt übertreiben sie es mit Toss Musik.
Jetzt übertreiben sie es.
Ja.
Jetzt bedanke ich mich bei euch fürs Zuschauen.
Hier könnt ihr ein Video über eine Bäckerei Fachverkäuferin anschauen.
Hier könnt ihr den...
Alles klar, jetzt wirst du auch als Bäckermeister verdient.
Und man muss sagen, das war halt mal wieder richtig no Bullshit.
Der Kerl arbeitet halt wirklich.
Nicht wie die Projektmanagerin oder wen hatten wir da sonst noch.
Den, ähm...
Diesen Konsultentyp oder so.
Die alle irgendwie den ganzen Tag nichts gemacht haben.
Der hat halt wirklich, der ist auf die Arbeit gefahren und hat dann halt einfach gearbeitet.
War ich das?
Ich weiß nicht, also mein Katzenklo ist relativ simpel.
Die Katze pinkelt da rein oder kackt da rein.
Und dann habe ich so eine Schaufel und macht das raus und das war's dann.
Ich wüsste nicht, was da so...
So kompliziert sein kann.
Der Salesforce Copypaster.
Stimmt, den hatten wir auch noch.
Leute, ich war jetzt dreieinhalb Stunden non.
Ich gehe jetzt essen, ich habe Hunger.
12.37 Uhr.
Pippo-Fat-Time.
Pippo-Fat, Pippo-Fat.
Und was ich essen will, wahrscheinlich noch ein paar Nudeln, die übrig sind.
Also wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream, macht's gut, bis dann, see you.